Mesdames et Messieurs chers collègues je
vous souhaite donc la la bienvenue à
cette audition publique de l'OPEX de
l'Office parlementaire d'évaluation des
des choix scientifiques et
technologiques et consacré donc au
développement des réacteurs nucléaires
innovants en France c'est une audition
publique l'office parlementaire a a déjà
travaillé sur cette question sur cette
notion de l'innovation en matière de
réacteur en particulier dans un rapport
de juillet 2021 intitulé l'énergie
nucléaire du futur et les conséquences
de l'abandon du projet de réacteur
nucléaire de 4e génération qui
s'appelait donc Astrid et que j'avais
l'honneur de mener de corapporter avec
le député Thomas gassillou à l'époque et
dans le cadre de ce rapport nous avions
formulé un certain nombre de de
préconisations certaines sont en voie de
se concrétiser par exemple fédérer les
pays européens favorables à au nucléaire
renforcer les moyens qui sont sont
dévolue à la fois à l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire et à l'Institut de
radioprotection et de sûreté nucléaire
ou encore prolongé sur plusieurs années
le soutien accordé au projet de petit
réacteur dont on entend beaucoup parler
petit réacteurs à eut pressurisé
français 2 ans et demi donc après la la
publication de de ce rapport il nous
paraissait utile de faire un point sur
le développement des réacteurs
nucléaires innovant quelle que soit la
la technologie en France cette audition
va comporter euh quatre séquences
distinctes avec deux table rondes la
première table ronde nous permettra
d'entendre quatre start-up que je
remercie d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation qui développe donc des
réacteurs à neutron rapid donc avec un
focus particulier bien sûr sur la
fermeture du cycle qui je le rappelle
est toujours inscrite dans la loi
française la seconde table ronde
montrera avec les représentants deedf du
jfen et de New World que les innovations
concernent aussi la technologie des
réacteurs à haut pressurisé celle qui
euh qui occupe si je peux dire le parc
actuel et c'est le pôle de compétitivité
nucléaire Vallé qui fera le lien le
trait d'union entre ces deux tables
rondes la matinée se conclura par une
intervention coordonnée de de l'ASN et
de
l'IRSN sur l'accompagnement de la
certification c'est un point évidemment
important certification des solutions
techniques
innovantes accompagnement fondamental
pour la réussite s de l'innovation en
matière
nucléaire j'ai également sollicité la
participation à nos débats de des
représentants de la cne2 la Commission
nationale d'évaluation des recherches et
études relativ à la gestion des matières
et des déchets radioactifs il y a des
acronymes qui sont quand même plutôt
plutôt pratiques cette cne2 sera
représent représenté par l'un de ses
membres Philippe gayochet ainsi que par
son secrétaire général et conseiller
scientifique François storer nous avions
nous l'avions en effet missionné en mars
2022 pour évaluer l'impact des nouveaux
projets de réacteur sur le cycle des
matières et des déchets radioactif et
nous avons eu le plaisir d'auditionner
il y a quelques semaines la
cne2 cette audition donc pour toute
cette patinée n'a évidemment pas la
prétension ni la vocation à à
l'exhaustivité elle marque simplement le
le commencement d'une série de travaux
relatif au au secteur nucléaire que je
souhaite initier prochaine étape prévue
étant une audition sur l'évaluation du
PNG mdr que j'ai évoqué en en début de
de réunion je rappelle que nos travaux
seront diffusés donc en direct sur le
site internet du Sénat et que la vidéo
sera ensuite disponible à la demande sur
les deux sites de l'assemblée et de la
de l'Assemblée nationale et du Sénat il
sera pas par ailleurs possible aux
internautes qui nous suivent comme nous
en avons pris l'habitude de soumettre
des questions en ligne par
l'intermédiaire de de la plateforme dont
le lien figure sur les pages Internet de
l'Office et certains de ces questions
pourront être recueillies et posé à la
fin des de l'audition et de nos travaux
voilà avant de commencer ces travaux je
donne la parole à notre premier
vice-président à savoir pierre
Henriet merci monsieur le Président
chers collègues mesdames messieurs à mon
tour je voudrais simplement pour cette
ouverture de de programme et en en guise
d'introduction vous dire à quel point au
sein du du Parlement nous nous regardons
avec beaucoup d'attention euh le sujet
du du développement des des réacteurs
nucléaires que ce soit sur les enjeux
évidemment des réacteurs à neutron
rapides comme des réacteurs à eau
pressciurisé c'est un ce sont des enjeux
qui évidemment nous nous nous touche
particulièrement au sein de de l'Office
parlementaire d'évaluation des choix
scientifiques et technologiques cont
tenu notamment de des informations que
nous pouvons
avoir s'agissant des différents
représentants que nous pouvons euh euh
entendre écouter et et et notamment
l'ensemble de la communauté scientifique
et de la recherche qui qui travaille sur
sur ces sujets on entend beaucoup de
choses avec parfois des des espoirs
concernant évidemment des des projets de
recherche de rupture c'est l'occasion
effectivement ce matin de de pouvoir
faire le point de situation sur sur le
développement de de ces innovations et
puis de pouvoir remplir notre rôle au
sein aussi du du grand public euh à
savoir quelles sont les les perspectives
qui sont réalistes euh sur ces
développements et et puis politiquement
savoir évidemment où est-ce que euh nous
politiques nous pourrons mettre les les
cadres qui permettront et bien de de
pouvoir dessiner l'avenir de de la
filière notamment dans la perspective de
reprise
euh des programmes nucléaires depuis
maintenant un peu plus d'un an et donc
très heureux que mes deux collègues
Stéphan pinoir et et Olga givverernet
puissent particulièrement plancher sur
ce sujet donc je ne serai pas plus long
merci à
vous merci euh
pierre nous allons donc pouvoir attaquer
les les séquences que j'ai j'ai présenté
tout à l'heure et je vais remercier je
vais donner la parole à à Olga
givverernet pour cette première table
ronde juste préciser que euh nous sommes
dans un dans des délais contraints qu' y
a un certain nombre de questions
probablement de nos nos collègues et des
auditeurs et donc les présentations on
va vous demander de faire des
présentations relativement resserrées
pour que nous puissions respecter les
délais il est nous avions prévu de
commencer la première table ronde à 9h40
il est 9h40 et donc HGA c'est à
toi merci beaucoup cher présidente cher
vice-président mes chers collègues et
oui j'ai l'honneur de mener cette table
ronde sur les start-up et l'innovation
dans le domaine des réacteurs à neutron
rapide et euh la fermeture du cycle
l'avenir du nucléaire est en train de
s'écrire il est porté par l'ingéniosité
et le dynamisme de nombreuses start-up
de l'ordre de 80 à travers le monde
cette première table ronde réunit quatre
start-ups merci à à vous et vous
développez de nouveaux réacteurs à
neutron rapides ce sera l'occasion de
prendre connaissance de leur de vos
projets et de comprendre de quelle façon
ils s'inscrivent dans la logique de
fermeture du cycle du combustible en
effet notre pays a fait le choix d'un
cycle du combustible nucléaire dit ferm
qui consiste à traiter les combustibles
usés pour récupérer les matières
valorisables uranium et plutonium cette
stratégie trouverait sa pleine mesure
avec le déploiement de réacteurs
nucléaires à neutrons rapides ils sont
capables de multirecycler le combustible
user et d'utiliser les matières
nucléaires présentes sur notre
territoire avec à la clé plusieurs
centaines d'années de ressources
énergétiques le développement d'un tel
réacteur est d'ailleurs prévu par la loi
du 28 juin
2006 alors vous l'aurez compris euh nous
voulons tous saoir sur le cycle du
combustible les technologies les
matériaux critiques les déchets et les
sous produits de fission savoir aussi
dans quel délai nous pouvons compter
dessus et notre temps est compté
aujourd'hui je vais pas prendre plus la
parole vous l'aurez compris je suis la
maître du temps pour cette première
table ronde et donc pour 7 minutes je la
donne au représentants de Nara Jean-Luc
Alexandre son président fondateur et
Christophe Béard son directeur amo donc
assistance de maîtrise d'ouvrage et CTO
chief technical officer directeur
technique en français habitué des
obditions de l'opest vous étiez
également directeur de l'énergie
nucléaire au CEA donc narea est
l'acronyme de nucléar bondant affable
resourceful energy for all et lauréa de
l'appel à projet réacteur nucléaire
innovant de l'ANR je vous en prie c'est
à vous
merci mesdames Messieurs les
parlementaires mesdames messieurs merci
infiniment de nous inviter pour avoir le
l'opportunité de présenter narea Nara
c'est une société qui a été créée il y a
3 ans à présent et qui vise à fournir de
l'électricité et de la chaleur décarboné
à des industriels c'est déjà ça le point
de départ qui est très important pour
comprendre comment nous essayons de
participons de participer à la
décarbonation et et aux enjeux
climatiques donc comment nous faisons ça
nous sommes partis comme vous l'avez
rappelé euh du cycle de la matière
puisque nous sommes bien sûr nous
inscrivons dans la fermeture du cicle de
la matière et nous avons voulu choisir
une technologie qui avait déjà démontré
son sa capacité à pouvoir éradiquer
certains produits de vie très longue
c'est bien ces équipes sont bien ces
matières que nous allons aller chercher
et donc nous avons choisi un petit
réacteur de 40 mW électriques ou 80 MW
thermiqu alors pour vous faire une idée
c'est ça permet de fournir grosso modo
la consommation résidentielle d'une
ville comme Bordeaux Strasbourg
Montpellier ou Nantes à peu près mais ça
permet également d'alimenter des gros
îlots industriels que ça peut être des
des gros fourneaux des gros usines de
voiture par exemple ce sont des modules
de 40 mW les plus grosses usines de
dessalement d'eau de mer dans le monde
font 40 mW dans les dans les zones en
stress hydrique donc d'avoir une petite
structure qui permet de délivrer
rapidement à des industriels c'est
quelque chose qui est très utile c'est
très compact ça tient sur un container
qui fait à peu près la taille d'un
autobus ça c'est l'illo nucléaire puis
après si vous avez besoin de faire
l'électricité vous avez un deuxième hlo
qui fait encore la taille d'un autobus
et là vous transformez votre chaleur en
électricité alors nous avons choisi un
réacteur à sel fondu qui avait été
démontré aux États-Unis au siècle
dernier qui a donné satisfaction nous
avons combiné ça avec bien sûr les
neutrons rapides pour pouvoir fissionner
le plutonium et à terme des actines
mineures et de l'uranium et nous
combinons tout ça nous miniaturisons
tout ça dans un tout petit container qui
nous permet nous affranchir d'eau pour
refroidir le réacteur ce qui veut dire
que ce réacteur n'a pas besoin d'être à
côté d'une source froide qui est l'eau
donc ni à côté d'une rivière ni à côté
de la mer deuxièmement ça permet de ne
pas avoir de prélèvement et donc
d'impact sur la ressource en E donc pas
de réchauffement d'eau puisque c'est au
niveau de la convection naturelle que
s'effectue ce refroidissement au niveau
pilot pilotabilité cette technologie est
assez prometteuse puisqu'elle permet
d'avoir une une pilotabilité qui
s'approche de celle de l'hydro
c'est-à-dire ça permet d'avoir ce qu'on
appelle de la pilotabilité quasiment
instantané et qui permet de compenser
par exemple l'intermittence des énergies
renouvelables donc c'est un complément
idéal aux énergies renouvelables mais
c'est également un complément parfait
pour pour accompagner la charge qui
n'est jamais continue d'une usine et
donc ça permet de soulager le l'accès à
la matière comme je disais donc
électricité chaleur c'est ça qui est
très important chaleur très haute
température 650° qui répond à beaucoup
de procédés industriels et chaleur
fatale bien entendu à 75°gr quand on
fait électricité ce qui permet en même
temps de pouvoir chauffer des bâtiments
et donc d'apporter une réponse la plus
globale possible au besoins industriels
nous sommes 175 collaborateurs
aujourd'hui premier collaborateur on va
dire que c'était début janvier 2022 donc
ça fait une croissance rapide nous
sommes toujours en croissance rapide
financé sur fonds privés français qui
sont des family office français
aujourd'hui et nous allons lancer là la
série a c'est pour lever plus d'argent
pour aller vers le prototype nous
planifions d'être sur le marché d'ici
2030 à partir de 2030 ce qui veut dire
queeectivement c'est une cadence assez
soutenu pour faire toutes les
démonstrations de sûreté de sécurité
nécessaires sur des petits objets qui
ont vocation à être fabriqués en grande
série puisqu'il n'y aura pas beaucoup de
génie civil sur place c'est aussi la
nouveauté c'est que vous fabriquez 100 %
de votre réacteur dans une usine et vous
venez mettre uniquement la charge du
combustible une fois que le réacteur a
été transporté sur son sur son lieu
définitif et donc ça vous donne une
grande souplesse ça vous donne aussi des
grandes cadences de production et donc
une fiabilité
supplémentaire je m'arrête sur ce point
je passe la parole à à Christophe B qui
va vous expliquer notre cycle de la
matière que nous avons prévu madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés mesdames et messieurs merci je
vais m'adosser sur la présentation qui
figure sur l'ensemble des écrans mais en
introduction je souhaitais rappeler que
pour nous lorsque nous avons commencé à
travailler au sein de Nara nous avons eu
immédiatement à l'esprit le cycle du
combustible alors j'avais pas beaucoup
de mérite puisque j'étais pendant
plusieurs années responsable d'Astrid au
sein du CEA ceci étant donc ce que vous
voyez sur ce sur ces présentations tout
en haut pour faire simple c'est le cycle
du combustible nucléaire actuel
nécessaire pour les parcs REP de façon
simplifiée et nous avons regardé de
quelle façon il nous était possible de
venir nous brancher sur ce cycle du
combustible alors on va procéder de la
façon suivante on va parler de la
fabrication des selles combustibles nos
Seles combustibles vont utiliser du
plutonium vont utiliser de l'uranium
appauvri
et des selles ce plutonium d'où vient-il
notre idée est qu'il provienne à terme
de la
Hague nous savons que normalement la hag
les capacités de la Hague ù devrai être
revue à l'horizon 2040 et dans notre
idée il serait bon qu'à ce moment-là
soit pris en compte nos propres
besoins en particulier en capacité de
production de plutonium sachant que
probablement je ne veux pas m'engager à
la place de DF le DF continuera à
fabriquer du MOX pour les réacteurs à
haut pressurisé mais ce que nous
souhaitons nous c'est qu'il y ait un
flux euh qui euh provienne de cette
usine de lague c'est ce qui est noté
extension
euh séparation euh pour pouvoir nous
fournir euh en plutonium comme je vous
l'ai dit euh nous allons utiliser de
l'uranium dans une première étape de
l'uranium appauvri pour fabriquer notre
selle simultanément en parallèle il est
nécessaire pour des raisons liées à la
création de chlore 36 alors je vais pas
être très précis simplement ce qu'il
faut retenir c'est que le cor chlore 36
est un problème pour
l'endra parce que c'est un corps qui si
on le met en stockage profond va se
retrouver pourrait se retrouver en tout
cas dans les premiers à l'exutoire donc
on va faire une séparation isotopique
euh le chlore naturel contient deux
isotopes euh le 35 et le 37 et ce qu'on
va essayer de faire c'est de trier ces
isotopes par un procédé de séparation
isotopique pour sortir le maximum de
chlore
37 donc nous fabriquons notre
combustible et nous le l'injectons dans
nos réacteur une fois que ce combustible
est usé aujourd'hui nos objectifs de
durée de fonctionnement sont de l'ordre
de 3 à 4 ans journée équivalent en
pleine puissance nous déchargeons ce
combustible et à nouveau comme nous ne
souhaitons pas développer un procédé de
retraitement nouveau nous utilisons ce
qui est noté ici atelier passerelle pour
faire deux choses d'abord pour extraire
du sel alors pourquoi on veut extraire
du sel tout simplement parce que les
colis de verre qui existent actuellement
à la Hague
pour conditionner les déchets de haute
activité vie longue ne supporte pas trop
de sel donc on va extraire du sel par ça
tombe bien on va le réinjecter dans
l'unité de fabrication des selles
combustibles je vais vous demander de de
conclure si vous le voulez bien bien je
vous ai présenté ici le cyle du
combustible tel que vu par les réacteurs
à cel fondu et juste deux petits points
de conclusion madame la Présidente 1 il
y a pas d'innovation forte s'agissant
des unités de retraitement qui existe
actuellement et de ces deux systèmes
peuvent fonctionner en parallèle
réacteur pressurisé réacteur à C fondu
j'ai terminé très bien je vous remercie
beaucoup et si nous pouvons avoir le
schéma qui nous qui nous est présenté
nous pourrons revenir vers vous avec
d'autres questions si besoin je vais
vous présenter ensuite la société
exana et sont présent Sylvain Nizou son
CEO et PA
le CTO et cofondateur qui vont nous
présenter leur projet toujours en 7
minutes vous le
savez et SMM du CEA en fait exana
conçoit un réacteur à neutron rapide
refroidi au sodium c'est bien ça tout à
fait je vous en prie bonjour à tous
mesdames et messieurs les députés les
sénateurs monsieur le Président l'OPEX
donc je suis
silvanizou je suis le président et
cofondateur de cette société qui est
effectivement
mé une spin-off du CEA qui porte la
conception d'un réacteur nucléaire
modulaire de 4e génération par d'un SMR
ou d'un Amr advanced modular
réacteur qui s'appuie sur cette
technologie des réacteurs à neutron
rapide refroidi au
sodium l'objectif de ce système de cette
solution c'est d'apporter une solution
crédible et alternative à l'utilisation
des combustibles fossiles dans
l'industrie en remplacement du P du gaz
et du charbon en fournissant de la
chaleur à haute température à 500°r et
de l'électricité de façon très flexible
ça c'est notre objectif le le système
que l'on propose est un réacteur
modulaire de 400 MW thermiqu plusieurs
réacteurs deux réacteurs sont couplés
ensemble et donc délivre 800 MW
thermiques équivalent à 300 MW électriqu
associé à un dispositif de stockage de
chaleur et de l'énergie qui permet
d'acheminer l'énergie vers l'utilisateur
de manière très flexible et de dissocier
le fonctionnement et le rythme du
réacteur de la consommation et de rythme
de consommation de l'utilisateur notre
objectif c'est d'être en capacité de
déployer cette technologie de la
commercialiser de démarrer une tête de
série industrielle en 2035 je parle pas
d'un prototype d'un démonstrateur mais
bien d'une tête de série à l'échelle 1
en 2035 sur un site français avec
l'objectif de pouvoir déployer d'ici à
2050 une dizaine d'installations en
France au service des zones
industrielles les plus consommatrices et
les plus émérices de CO2 pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a fait le choix de cette
technologie pour trois raisons simples
la première c'est la maturité et la
crédibilité de la technologie du cœur
technologique qui est embarqué dans ce
cette solution innovante en effet on
s'appuie sur la technologie des
réacteurs neutron rapide refroidi au
sodium c'est une technologie qui est
aujourd'hui considérée la plus mature
des réacteur de 4e génération qui
bénéficie de plus de 400 ans de
fonctionnement cumulé de réacteurs à
l'échelle
mondiale ici en France nous avons déjà
pu valider au travers du réacteur
expérimental phennix la validité et la
pertinence des matériaux donc qualifier
des matériaux nous avons également
qualifié du combustible MOX pour
crnr le projet le réacteur super Phenix
ont permis de démontrer la faisabilité à
l'échelle industrielle et à grande
échelle de cette technologie avec sur
les dernières années un taux de
fonctionnement de 96 % et puis le projet
Astrid a permis de renouveler les
compétences et également de qualifier et
développer nouveaux outils de de calcul
la deuxème raison
importante j'oublie un point aujourd'hui
exana va capitaliser sur cette
connaissance ce savoir-faire développé
en France en bénéficiant d'un accès à la
propriété intellectuelle et au
savoir-faire du CEA et du f au profit de
ce projet la deuxième raison importante
qui justifie le choix cette technologie
ce sont les perform ance aujourd'hui en
fournissant cette chaleur à l'industrie
qui est vraiment la part énergétique le
vecteur énergétique le plus attendu par
les grands consommateurs avant même
l'électricité en fournissant de la
chaleur et en particulier de la la
chaleur haute température et de
l'électricité on va pouvoir résoudre
cette problématique de l'ultradépendance
au pétrole au gaz et au charbon en
particulier dans l'acier la chimie le
ciment la production d'hydrogène ou de
carburant c'est équivalent aujourd'hui
une journée de fonctionnement de cette
solution c'est 200 tonnes d'hydrogène
bacarbone qui sont produits la troisème
raison qui justifie le choix de cette
technologie c'est qu'elle permet
d'engager la fermeture du cycle du
combustible nucléaire c'est une évidence
elle permet de s'engager également dans
un nucléire qui est durable euh en
utilisant un combustible MOX produit
évidemment à partir de plutonum et
d'uranium appauvri des ressources
disponible en quantité importantes et
qui représente des quantités d'énergie
considérables pour plusieurs siècles
c'est également une stratégie qui permet
encore d'améliorer l'impact
environnemental de cette solution sortir
d'une stratégie aussi extractiviste
d'importation de réduction de la
dépendance à des prix de marché d'AM
minera et d'une certaine manière
regagner en terme de souveraineté
énergétique et de maîtriser le coût de
son énergie je vous remercie et je vais
passer la parole à Paul goté mon associé
oui bonjour quelques détails en plus sur
XANA donc moi Paul Goé je viens du CEA
j'ai travaillé à phenniix en
exploitation donc réacteur sodium qui a
fonctionné jusqu'en 2009 à marcool puis
sur le projet Asri dans surterre en
conception et globalement dans
l'innovation réacteur au CEA alors
quelques mots sur xada en plus sur le
design il s'agit pas juste de faire un
RNR comme avant il y a bien une
conception nouvelle du réacteur qu'on
veut modulaire un réacteur plus petit
plus compact plus sûr aussi rappelons
que la filière sodium le sodium c'est un
métal liquide qui n'a pas besoin d'être
en pression donc ça c'est très
intéressant pour la sûreté c'est un
métal liquide
qui permet de refroidir aussi le
réacteur juste avec de l'air en
convection naturelle donc si on a pas
d'électricité pas d'eau on a pas de
problème de refroidissement et tout ça
c'est encore plus vrai quand le réacteur
est assez petit donc nous on est sur une
gamme 400 MW thermique donc qui est pas
un petit petit c'est plutôt un gros SMR
c'est quand même une puissance assez
importante mais qui qui est quand même
assez petit pour simplifier le design du
réacteur et le rendre plus sûr autre
spécificité du système exana c'est qu'on
associe le réacteur nucléaire avec un
système de stockage thermique stockage
de la chaleur qui va avoir plusieurs
intérêts un intérêt c'est d'assurer de
la flexibilité c'est-à-dire que plus
pour fournir l'industriel ou fournir de
l'électricité de manière très flexible
on va pouvoir jouer sur ce stockage de
chaleur plutôt que sur la variation de
puissance du réacteur ce qui va être
très intéressant pour accroître la durée
de vie du réacteur et et et sa
simplification aussi et c'est aussi un
intérêt de se découpler de la partie
nucléaire de la partie industrielle euh
parce qu'on veut fournir directement de
la chaleur à l'industrie il aussi un
intérêt qui est d'enlever la présence
d'eau dans le système puisqu'on a un
système avec un un un réacteur sodium un
stockage de chaleur avec des selles
nitrates fondu et l'eau qui est donc à
l'extérieur de de l'installation
nucléaire donc sur la fermeture du cycle
pour être un peu plus précis donc nous
on utilise bien évidemment du MOX le MOX
RNR mélange d'uranium appauvri et
plutonium qui vient des combustibles
usés ce MOX il est qualifié il est est
fabricable il est retraitable ça c'est
la vraie vie qu'on a vécu à phenniix à
super phenniix les Russes ont annoncé il
y a 15 jours avoir moxer complètement
leur réacteur sodium c'est ce qu'on
savait faire il y a 50 ans le
multirecyclage du plutonium c'est aussi
une réalité donc nous ce qu'on a voulu
vérifier c'est qu'on pouvait bien
accepter plusieurs plutonium du
plutonium issu des REP ou des des repes
moxé et donc avoir une certaine
versatilité souplesse vis-à-vis de la le
combustible le réacteur il est assez
gros pour être ce qu'on appelle
isogénérateur donc qui consomme autant
de combustible qu'il en produit et ça
c'est ce qui ouvre vraiment la voie au
nucléaire durable c'est-à-dire qu'on
veut pas juste brûler des déchets si on
dit un peu un peu de façon simple mais
on veut bien ouvrir la voie à devenir
l'Arabie Saoudite de l'énergie
décarbonée avec cette techno et pour
conclure mon propos liminire madame la
députée euh je dirais qu'est-ce qui nous
anime dans dans exana c'est de reprendre
un peu la la voie du progrès cet esprit
de conquête qu'on a eu en France et donc
pas s'arrêter à simplement dire genc
c'est pour la fin du siècle je pense que
c'est important de le faire maintenant
vraiment et donc très bien je vous
remercie merci beaucoup merci Monsieur
Nizou et goté pour cette présentation
nous allons à présent écouter Nicolas
breton ce de stellaria et Lucas tardieux
son architecte réacteur Guillaume
campioni directeur technique de staria
est aussi présent il est à distance non
il sera pas là pardon excusez-moi euh et
et donc stellaria est aussi sm du CEA
elle propose une nouvelle génération de
réacteurs à Sal fondu à destination des
grands industriels c'est à vous oui
bonjour je suis le président de
stellaria je vous remercie pour cette
audience stellaria conçoit le premier
réacteur à selle fondu donc à cœur
liquide de 110 MW électrique 2 x 110 MW
électrique qui autorégénère son
combustible au sein même du cœur
le réacteur Stellarium a été développé
dans le cadre d'une alliance
industrielle avec Orano avec le CEA et
aussi avec industriel avec Technip avec
Scher électrique stellaria né d'une
rencontre justement entre des experts
techniques d'astride des des réacteurs
de 4e génération du CA et des experts
des besoins
industriels issus de Schneider
électrique et qui connaissent très bien
les besoins desélectro intensifs donc
dans les mines dans les Data Center euh
dans les zones portuaires et cetera euh
on a été aussi à l'écoute des besoins
d'orano et de DF notamment évidemment
pour la fermeture du cycle que nous
adressons complètement l'objectif est de
fournir une tête de série d'ici
2035 nous adressons deux grandes
familles de besoins euh d'un côté les
grands clients industriels qui doivent
fonctionner 24h/ 24 avec de l'énergie
décarbonée à Bac coup produite en juste
à temps à chaque seconde de l'année
suivant rapidement la courbe de la
demande pour réindustrialiser et
électrifier ce pays
il nous faut garantir des factures
d'énergie stables à long terme d'autre
part la filière industrielle actuelle a
comme objectif évidemment de fermer le
cycle de de valoriser pleinement
l'uranium et le plutanium issu des
réacteurs auessurisés les matières
contenues dans les combustibles usés et
si possible d'incinérer laaméritium et
les actines mineurs notre stratégie est
de donc de diminuer la dépendance aux
mines étrangères et d'atteindre la
souverainé
énergétique la somme de ces besoins si
l'on voit bien converge vers une
technologie de rupture la création d'une
nouvelle filière à combustible liquide
une filière à neutron rapide les
combustibles liquides ont deux avantages
majeur d'abord ils ont été inventés aux
États-Unis pour fournir une électricité
très rapidement commandable à la hausse
et à la baisse c'est donc une
alternative régionale décarbonée à la
centrale à gaz au-delà des centrales euh
existant des centrales nationales et
puis euh évidemment c'est un complément
aux énergies intermittentes le
Stellarium peut aussi s'arrêter très
rapidement grâce à la dilatation
naturelle des combustibles liquides ce
qui apporte une sûreté intrinsèque par
conception y compris en cas de perte
totale du circuit
primaire par exemple il fonctionne à
pression atmosphérique euh et en
convection naturelle ce qui empêche
naturellement le dégazage en cas
d'accident il n'y a pas de risque de
fondre de cœur car son cœur est
naturellement
fondu la zone d'exclusion sûreté est
donc très limitée ce qui permet un
déploiement nouveau dans des grandes
zones industrielles et nous avons choisi
des zones industrielles où la le service
de sécurité
existe on peut fournir donc de fois 120
MW électriques en autonomie pendant 15
ans sur une surface compacte de la
taille de d'un à deux terrains de
football ce qui permet de résoudre le
problème du foncier dans des zones qui
sont plus compliquées le combustible
reste 15 ans sur site ce qui évite le
des transports inutiles donc une
autonomie totale pendant 15 ans
ensuite ils fournissent la capacité de
multirecycler les combustibles issus des
réacteur repressurisé s'inscrivant
parfaitement dans la stratégie de
fermeture du cycle le Stellarium est
tolérant et peut fonctionner avec
différents type de
combustible des combustibles liquides
qui sont mélangés dans le sel donc on
parle ici de évidemment du MOX de
l'exmox aussi des MOX qui sont très
dégradés de
l'URT et puis aussi de torium faut
savoir qu'on a 9000 tonnes de torium sur
notre sol et 320000 tonnes d'uranium
naturel aussi sur notre sol qui sont
valorisables qui sont des matières
fertiles il permet ainsi d'obtenir une
diversification des approvisionnements
et une gestion de l'inventeur du
plutonium civil et une véritable
souveraineté améliorée
grâce à la fertilisation de de de des
matières des matières qu'on a
aujourd'hui sur notre sol les déchets
donc de haute activité peuvent être
transmutés dans notre réacteur réduisant
ainsi la la demi-ve des de ces déchets
de 300000 ans à 300 ans la demi-vie
moyenne au-delà de la au-delà de la
valorisation de l'uranium de
retraitement et du pu issu des du MOX le
Stellarium ouvre la perspective nouvelle
pour de renouveler 100 % du combustible
pendant son fonctionnement normal et il
remplace instantanément les matières
fissionnées par des matières fertilisées
au sein même de son cœur ce qui permet
de déjà d'avoir une fermeture du cercle
du cycle pardon au sein même du cœur en
d'autres termes c'est comme si votre
voiture avait une quantité d'essence
dans son
réservoir autant d'essence au bout de
100000 km qu'au
début ça permettra d'avoir une stabilité
de prod
électrique inégalé et une grande
continuité de servic nous pourrons donc
garantir une facture énergétique stable
et prévisible pour les industriel pour
réussir ce projet nous avons trois
besoins immédiats
premièrement nous pour pouvoir réaliser
des expériences scientifiques rapidement
les startup auront besoin de la mise en
place de zones de de zones pour faire
des expériences nucéaire et la question
qu'on se pose c'est est-ce qu'on
pourrait avoir des zones startup qui
pourra être dédié qui permettrai sur les
sites de recherche existants d'accélérer
les road map de l'ensemble de ces
start-ups deuxièmement pour réaliser ces
expériences nous aurions besoin de
procédures accélérées pour l'obtention
des autorisations pour réaliser ces
expériences dont la taille est est très
petite pourrait-on par exemple modifier
les usages des installations nucléaires
de base existantes plus rapidement pour
pouvoir
utiliser les utiliser plus vite pour des
nouvelles expériences les autorisations
seront bien sûr dans le respect le plus
strict des normes de sûreté mais comme
comme préconisé dans le rapport de
l'OPEX la simplicité des autorisations
devra être gradué à l'enjeu radiologique
réel des expériences de très petite
taille enfin nous aurons besoin de créer
un sel des cel combustible de recherche
en un temps record avec nos partenaires
or rano et ca qui sont nécessaires
évidemment pour pour faire ces
expériences la simplification des
autorisations pour l'utilisation de ces
combustibles de recherche
sera aussi un enjeu majeur pour aller
vite à plus long terme il faudra
envisager bien sûr la perspective de
nouveaux sites nucléaire permettant de
déployer dans des zones industrielles
ces petits réacteurs avec la crise
énergétique et l'explosion des besoins
en uranium des besoins et des prix aussi
l'heure des réct l'heure des des
réacteurs à neutron rapide à mon avis à
sonné les réacteurs à neutron rapid sont
la meilleure solution environnementale
pour ouvrir une une énergie à l'échelle
des besoins industriels une énergie
souveraine une énergie sûre une énergie
décarbonée une énergie durable et une
énergie que nous pouvons renouveler pour
des siècles merci je vous remercie et
merci de votre
concision nous allons donc terminer
cette table ronde avec l'intervention de
nucléo représenté par Ludovic
vendrich j'espère que je vous ai pas
écorné directeur général pour la France
et Stéphane kalalpena directeur de la
sûreté des processus réglementaires
nucléo est une société d'origine
italienne implanté à Lyon nos amis
italiens ont en effet conservé un haut
niveau scientifique en physique
nucléaire malgré l'abandon sans doute
provisoire de son utilisation pour
l'énergie nucléo développe des réacteurs
nucléaires rapides refroidis au plomb
c'est à vous merci bonjour et merci pour
cette invitation à à présenter nucléo
qui est une entreprise donc sur fond
privé qui est s fondé en 2021 euh donc à
l'initiative de de de fondateur italiens
comme vous l'avez souligné qui s'est
implanté au Royaume-Uni dans un premier
temps et en 2022 en avril
2022 a créé une une entité en France
basée à Lyon euh dans le but
d'accompagner la la renaissance du
nucléaire que connaissons tous ici
autour de la table annoncé par le par le
Président nous avons été ensuite lauréa
de France 2030 dans le cadre de l'appel
à projet réacteur nucléaire
innovant à peu près au milieu de de
cette année notre vocation donc c'est
d'être un acteur compétitif de la
transition énergétique et de proposer un
nucléaire durable comme l'ont évoqué les
les collègues qui me qui m'ont précédé
euh donc nous avons un concept de
réacteur SMR donc small modul réacteur
de génération 4 réacteur à neutron
rapide refroidi au plomb une technologie
donc également souligné précédemment qui
se base sur un un acqui conséquent euh
en France euh au travers des des
réacteurs RNR précédents et également 25
ans de de Red significatif sur les
réacteurs au plomb en Europe et en
particulier en
Italie alors pourquoi un nucléaire
durable évidemment on a tous également
parlé donc la fermeture du cycle du
combustible avec l'utilisation du MOX
qui est donc un mélange de plutonium et
d'uranium appauvri euh un recyclage des
matières valorisables qui sont issus des
des déchets nucléaires que nous avons
sur notre sol français et également
présent bien évidemment dans d'autres
pays nucléaires en collaboration avec
les acteurs français du cycle nous avons
vocation à nous inscrire dans un dans un
écosystème
euh collaboratif qui qui ne concerne pas
uniquement un un projet nucléo et donc
de travailler en en étroite
collaboration avec les acteurs
historiques
euh et et donc
l'objectif est évidemment développer un
réacteur
nucléaire dont la puissance est de de
200 MW électrique mais également une une
usine de fabrication de de combustible
MOX je je viens de l'évoquer MOX RNR qui
qui est une par particularité qu'il
différencie du du MOX actuellement
utilisé dans les dans les réacteurs à
haut préciurisé actuelle
euh et et et donc un nucléaire vertueux
et et
durable les applications sont multi
je je vais pas les détailler ici mais la
la celle qui nous occupe principalement
c'est évidemement la génération
d'électricité et l'alimentation du
réseau nous avons en 2021 début début
2022 réaliser deux levé deux premières
levées de fond donc de 200 puis 300
millions d'euros et nous sommes en cours
d'une troisème levée de fond de de avec
un objectif d'un milliard de manière à
pouvoir d'ors et déjà avant et
progresser sur la conception et la
préparation de la construction de notre
premier réacteur qui sera un
démonstrateur industriel à horizon
2030 le calendrier donc c'est d'abord ce
qu'on appelle un
précurseur d'ici 2026 qui va consist
consister pardon à une installation
d'ESS qui sera réalisée sur le site de
brassimony en Italie qui est un un site
de
l'ENA puis donc de développer à la fois
un démonstrateur industriel sur le sol
français ainsi qu'une usine de
fabrication de combustible MOX comme je
l'ai évoqué ici en
France
le l'usine de fabrication ayant pour
pour objectif calendaire
euh l'horizon
2029 nous souhaitons nous appuyer sur
une une une une Supply Chain européenne
donc qui sera intégré dès les phase de
conception euh de manière à pouvoir
respecter ce ce ce ces objectifs de de
de livraison assez ambitieux euh et donc
sur un modèle de partenariat voire
d'acquisition d'un certain nombre de de
fournisseurs stratégiques sur sur la
chaîne du du
nucléaire nos priorités actuelles sont
donc euh tout d'abord une une certaine
forme de labellisation par le
gouvernement français de nucléo en tant
que fabricant euh de combustible MOX RNR
c'est évidemment une une nouveauté dans
le euh dans dans l'écosystème actuel
puisque puisque c'est le le monopole de
d'un acteur aujourd'hui historique euh
donc c'est un point qui est évidemment
important pour pouvoir continuer à
déployer notre notre projet et également
un appui du du gouvernement pour
l'acquisition de deux sites nucléaires
existant euh l'un pour pouvoir euh
implanter notre premier réacteur
démonstrateur industriel comme je l'ai
dit à horison 2030 mais avec un besoin
de connaissance de de la localisation
dans dans dans les meilleurs délais euh
et un autre site également pour l'usine
de fabrication de MOX que que l'on que
l'on vient d'évoquer je passe la parole
à mon collègue Stéphane calpena qui va
rentrer un peu plus dans le détail
technique de du réacteur merci beaucoup
Ludovic merci madame la députée monsieur
le le sénateur pour l'organisation de de
cette séance alors oui effectivement je
vais continuer sur sur le MOX donc
nucléo souhaite fabriquer du MOX mais
pas que pour les installation nucléo on
s'interdit pas bien sûr de travailler
avec nos avec nos collègues pour les
apprivisionner en en combustible puisque
c'est quand même euh une filière que
nous lançons et pas seulement un
réacteur hein c'est-à-dire la
fabrication du combustible euh utiliser
le combustible et le recyclage derrière
euh le plomb pourquoi le plomb en fait
on s'appuie quand même sur plusieurs
décennies d'expérience française en
terme de réacteur neutron rapide mais en
lieu et place du sodium on mettrait du
plomb euh sur le plomb il y a aussi
entre 25 et 30 ans de de recherche et
développement en Italie qui ont été
poursuivis suite à la fermeture de super
phennix faut savoir que beaucoup de
personnes à nucléo viennent de super
Phenix phennix et Astride également il y
avait beaucoup d'italien également à
super phenniix pour eux c'est la la
surgénération c'est c'est leur vie le
plomb remplace le sodium il il réagit
pas avec l'air et l'eau donc c'est c'est
un progrès on fonctionne aussi à
pression atmosphérique et une convection
naturelle qui a été démontrée pendant
plus de 25 ans qui fonctionne bien il y
a pas de fuite parce que tout se passe
dans une seule cuve he il y a pas de
circuit euh comme on peut le voir sur
les réacteurs apressurisés le réacteur
comme tous les rapides est
autostabilisant quand la température
monte un peu trop ça étouffe la la
réaction nucléaire donc il y a un
équilibre qui se fait en en condition
accidentelle qui est intéressante qui se
trouve probablement entre 600 et 700°r
il faut savoir que le plomb son son
ébultion est à 1740 donc on a une grosse
marge 1000 degr de marge donc on est on
veut valoriser cette cette marge auprès
de l'autorité de sûeté nucléaire et l'
RSN bien sûr il y a énormément de
détails à à démontrer et plusieurs
milliers de pages à mettre sur le papier
mais c'est vraiment la la volonté de de
nuclo de montrer la robustesse de de son
réacteur euh beaucoup de systèmes
passifs capacité de rétention aussi des
radionucléides par le plomb mais c'est
aussi le cas avec le sodium hein chez
chez mes camarades qui ont déjà été
valorisé à super Phenix on fait encore
de la recherche et développement avec
capsule corps Otello le précurseur dont
tu as parlé Ludovic le précurseur c'est
un réacteur en Italie mais pas nucléaire
on met des chaurettes électriques à la
place du combustible je vais vous
demander de pouvoir conclure s'il vous
plaît oui et il nous reste donc
plusieurs réunions en phase une à à à
poursuivre avec l'autorité de sité
nucléaire sur l'inspection service et
les aspects corrosion qui sont les
points regarder de près pour ce type de
réacteur je vous remercie merci beaucoup
merci à vous d'avoir pris le temps de de
nous expliquer je vous propose que nous
passions au au débat et donc aux
questions des parlementaires membres
membres de l'opexte et j'ai une première
question qui concerne du coup le le
combustible est-ce que vous avez été en
mesure de quantifier les besoins en
combustible dont vous aurez besoin et
comment vous les fournir
oui alors effectivement comme je vous le
disais tout à l'heure on s'est intéressé
très tôt au cycle on s'est intéressé
aussi au déploiement donc d'où vient le
combustible on l'a quantifié on a
quantifié les quantités de combustibles
nécessaires par réacteur est nécessaire
au déploiement d'une flotte d'où vient
le combustible de l'usine de
retraitement de l' upgradé comme je le
disais tout à l'heure quitte à faire
venir de de des combustibles usés de
l'étranger pour être retraité pour qu'il
puisse ensuite fournir du plutonium pour
nos besoins merci
ok de notre côté il faut environ 2
tonnes de MOX pour démarrer un réacteur
donc ça vous donne une ordre de grandeur
de du besoin ce MOX donc uranium
appauvri plutonium on sait le fabriquer
on en a fabriqué aux atpu à cadarche
pour les réacteurs phéniix et per
phenniix l'enjeu c'est de
réindustrialiser un atelier MOX RNR au
plus vite donc on a entendu nucléo qui
se positionnait sur ce sujet et Orano
aussi qui pourrait être un acteur
important vu que c'était l'acteur qui
était prévu pour alimenter le réacteur
Astrid en MOX donc nous on explore les
deux voies
merci euh côté stellaria le les calculs
nous donnent une bonne idée de ce que
consomme un réacteur et puis on a aussi
l'idée dans notre réacteur de la
régénération constante du combustible
donc finalement ça nous permet de
limiter on va dire les transports et
donc le besoin en usine de retraitement
puisqu'on retraite que tous les 15 ans
par acteur donc en fait les calculs sont
en train de déterminer quelle sera la
série pour bien qualifier le
besoin en terme de quantité nécessaire
pour alimenter le réacteur on est sur
des des ordres de grandeur équivalent de
l'ordre de tonnes sur sur le sur le
réacteur notre usine de de fabrication
de MOX est une usine qui a vocation à
être une usine modulaire euh avec une
capacité de de production qui démarrera
à 20 tonnes puis 40 puis 60 afin
d'accompagner le le déploiement du
parc au fil au fil des
années merci beaucoup euh je propose de
passer la parole à mon collègue
Alexandre SABATOU et puis ensuite
Jean-Luc
fugit merci monsieur le Président Madame
la la rapporteur euh merci beaucoup en
tout cas pour votre présentation je suis
très enthousiaste avec avec tous ces
projets qui qui sont en cours j'ai des
questions qui ont déjà été un peu posées
par enfin des affirmations qui ont déjà
été répondu par Monsieur breton à peu
près mais j'aimerais avoir l'avis de
vous autres euh qu'est-ce que vous
attendez concrètement des pouvoirs
publics est-ce que vous considérez être
soutenu dans vos projets suffisamment
attendez-vous plus de de notre part et
aussi est-ce que la réglementation et
les normes sont des obstacles important
pour le développement de vos
technologies ù est-ce que elle vous
semble adapté et j'aimerais que la SN
n'écoute pas trop les réponses pour pour
ne pas se fâcher merci merci je vous en
prie merci alors pour Nara d'abord on
remercie le les pouvoir public de nous
avoir accompagné dans France 2030 sur
l'appel à projet parce que c'est très
important pas forcément en terme de
montant ce qui est important c'est
d'envoyer un signal dans par rapport aux
investisseurs privés qui ont besoin de
voir que l'État est au côté que l'État y
croit donc ça c'est très important et on
vous remercie pour ça euh qu'est-ce
qu'on attend après au-delà de bien sûr
le le label il est important
d'accompagner les start-ups et et je
prêche aussi pour mes collègues parce
que il y a des il y a notamment des
outils et des ressources des assets on
va les appeler comme ça que l'État
dispose ou que l'État que la France a pu
développer ces dernières années et qu'il
faut qu'on puisse utiliser pour faire
nos démonstrations de sûreté je pense
par exemple aux outils de calculs
scientifiques qui sont homologués si on
veut réhomologuer un logiciel on va
partir sur des sur des durées
extrêmement longues si l'on peut
utiliser des logiciels qui existent et
qui sont homologués ça va nous permettre
de faire les bonnes démonstrations ça
c'est une chose après ce qui serait bien
c'est nous aider à trouver un site pour
mettre nos prototypes nous avons tous
des prototypes à mettre quelque part sur
des terrains qui soient plutôt
nucléarisés d'origine et donc ça peut
être un outil très important pour nous
aider pour raccourcir les calendriers
merci euh du côté exana aujourd'hui on
considère que c'est une vraie chance
d'avoir cet appel à projet France 2030
trécteur nucléaire innovant qui permet
de donner une dynamique forte et de
faire émerger euh des acteurs sur des
technologies existantes euh ou qui
doivent encore faire leur preuve de
concept ce qu'on considère aujourd'hui
très important c'est donner aussi les
moyens aux autorités de de sûreté pour
pouvoir avoir la dynamique la réactivité
les moyens d'expertiser rapidement euh
les projets dans le respect évidemment
des règles de sûreté euh on a cette
chance aussi en tout cas dans notre cas
d'avoir des autorités de sûreté qui ont
connu et qui pour une technologie RNR
sodium qui a déjà été licencié sur le
sol français donc on espère que sur ce
volet-là on va pouvoir bénéficier des
acquis du passé et puis dernier point le
essentiel la filière nucléaire
fonctionne sur ces deux jambes des
réacteurs du combustible euh par
conséquent la stratégie sur le
combustible est essentielle donner une
dynamique donner un élan avoir une
visibilité et faire une planification
sérieuse sur la partie combustible
devient essentiel aujourd'hui dans le
contexte où oui regardez autour de la
table des acteurs émergants sur les
concepts euh innovants arrivve côté
réacteur il faut la même chose côté
combustible très bien merci beaucoup
est-ce que vous voulez intervenir
également ouis j'ai j'ai déjà répondu
mais rapidement ce que je voulais dire
c'est que on se considère comme un
catalyseur aussi de la de la recherche
publique et euh et donc c'est c'est un
c'est c'est un projet gagnant gagnant
euh si on si on trouve les les moyens
ensemble euh d'accélérer les procédures
d'utiliser des installations existantes
qui ont beaucoup été développées années
70 et qui qui sont qui sont encore de
très bonne qualité de façon à à
pouvoir justement trouver des solutions
pour pour accélérer les road map puisque
on a aussi évidemment des contraintes
financières les investisseurs ont besoin
d'un retour rapide très bien
merci alors déjà je vrais souligner que
les les les les démarches et les actions
qui ont été faites par le gouvernement
depuis depuis un an et demi sont sont
sont assez exceptionnels et nous ont
permis de démarrer nos nos travaux et
notre implantation sur le sur le
territoire donc ça c'est un point
important aujourd'hui ce dont on a
encore besoin c'est comme on l'évoquait
peut-être d'intégrer de manière beaucoup
plus concrète et pragmatique dans
l'appel à projet réacteur nucléaire
innovant la part combustible elle est
aujourd'hui euh relativement ignoré ou
en tout cas écarté euh c'est c'est
essentiel aujourd'hui apporter cette
cette clarification pour pour nous
donner un instrument de travail et et
d'avancer sur sur le sujet et une
légitimité d'engager des fonds sur sur
ce développement à ça y est le
l'attribution de de de site comme on on
l'a tous évoqué euh on est financé comme
vous l'avez compris par des des capitaux
privés euh voilà qui qui qui qui
demandent des résultats à relativement
court terme et on est un peu dans cette
dans cette attente aujourd'hui d'une de
de décision euh du gouvernement parce
que on a compris que c'était à ce
niveau-là que ça se ça se passait euh
d'attribution de site très bien merci
beaucoup il nous reste pas beaucoup de
juste un point 30 secondes sur le sur
sur l'aspect sûreté qui
oui la question c'est comment vous
pouvez nous aider état donc bon des
efforts des efforts remarquables côté
ASN RSN pour vraiment nous appuyer et
nous suivre donc donner les moyens à ces
institutions pour pouvoir suivre les les
nouveaux pétitionnaire bien évidemment
mais aussi en terme de loi les
investisseurs privés il y a plusieurs
milliards qui sont prêts à être
donné aux Français pour lancer euh
lancer ses installations et ce qui nous
dit c'est que la timeline la durée de
temps pour obtenir un décret d'ation de
création c'est 6 ou 7 ans et on a le
droit de verser le premier béton
nucléaire j'appelle béton nucléaire le
béton destiné à aux bâtiments qui vont
accueillir les matières nucléaires donc
et pas le parking ouou la turbine on on
a très bien compris donc le béton
nucléaire on peut le verser en France
mais comme plus beaucoup de pays hein
pardon en Angleterre également euh
seulement quand on a le décret
d'autorisation de création et on voulait
savoir peut-être pour attirer ces
investisseurs qui trouvent que c'est
trop long si on commence 5 an de
construction 4 an de construction après
ces 7 ans vous imaginez bien plus une
année de de mise en service ça fait des
délais très longs qui sont pas
acceptables pour les investisseurs
privés donc afin de faire faire
peut-être certaines choses au parallèle
au risque et péril du pétitionnaire
c'est-à-dire commencer avec un permis
une autorisation bien sûr la
construction nucléaire avant le DAC et
si on n pas le DAC ben tant pis on aura
un bâtiment effectivement c'est c'est le
le risque industriel qui pr pris bien
sûr il faut que les conditions soient et
que la loi soit amendée du 22 juin 2023
merci beaucoup très bien compris merci
beaucoup Jean-Luc fugit pour une
question il nous restera 5 5 minutes
ensuite pour merci merci m la présidente
de cette audition danse et qui mais bon
très très très intéressante rapidement
peut-être euh peut-être parce que j'ai
pas tout compris notamment pour narea
moi j'aimerais savoir comment vous voyez
vraiment concrètement la la fermeture du
du cycle du combustible et pour vous et
peut-être pour d'autres même si ça a été
un petit peu évoqué excusez-moi de
demander des précisions on est dans un
système comme vous le savez de finances
publiqu qui qui qui est limité faut ch
par leur nom hein on est on doit on est
des des responsables ici euh comment
vous voyez le le financement donc de de
ces opérations de développement donc de
de ce nouveau nucléaire et puis de
manière générale certains d'entre vous
ont peut-être déjà un petit peu répondu
mais euh le texte de loi que nous avons
adopté donc en en juin dernier enfin qui
a été promulgué de bienir le 22 juinen
dernier euh sur le nouveau dispositif et
cetera ce qui vous paraît adapté à vos
c'est peut-être un petit peu ce qui a
été évoqué mais j'aimerais avoir la vie
un peu de tout le monde euh puisqu'on a
beaucoup travaillé sur la question des
pr et cetera et donc l'idée c'est de
voir si aujourd'hui le système est est
adapté à ce que vous vous
portez alors si je je je pense que on va
prendre toutes les questions en même
temps comme ça ce sera plus plus facile
je donne la parole à notre collègue
Daniel Salmond et puis et et puis Cédric
Davi
merci merci Madame
merci Madame la la rapporteur juste une
question quand même qui est assez
cruciale quel prix comptez-vous pour la
sortie de megawh hein parce que c'est
quand même un élément important je sais
que vous pariez tous sur l'effet de
série de ces de ces SMR ou Amr euh et on
voit bien ici que vous êtes dans un
système concurrentiel est-ce qu'il y
aura de la place pour plusieurs modèles
et à notre collègue pardon pour pour le
nom je vous je vous laisse vous
présenter je en prie il y a pas de souci
Maxime lené c'est ma première réunion de
l'OPEX donc on va apprendre à se bon la
mariée est très belle mais sur le MOX
sur lequel vous comptez tous les
informations qu'on a quand même sur le
zinmaox c'est quand même quelques
difficultés avec énormément de rebut
donc on verra si ça fonctionne vraiment
trois questions très rapides la première
c'est euh en fait pour que ça marche il
faut produire en série il faut produire
beaucoup est-ce que les est-ce qu'il y a
des usines en fait sans sans parler du
MOX du combustible mais de fabrication
des modules est-ce qu'elles sont là dans
quel délai elles arriveront euh et du
coup à quel rythme on aura des
puissances installées dans le pays pour
que ça puisse peut-être décarboner
deuxème question à quel prix tout ça ça
va se faire parce que partout où on a
lancé à chaque fois il y a eu des
retards je parle des SMR hein pas des OP
mais il y a eu des retards il y a eu des
surcouts news qu'elle vient d'abandonner
aux États-Unis après avoir dépensé
énormément d'argent public et troisème
question est-ce que vous souhaitez pas
seulement développer des concept mais
aussi réaliser
l'exploitation ce qui est le monopole de
DF pour l'instant merci merci beaucoup
et je propose de conclure les questions
par notre président Stéphane
piennoir merci oui juste une question
sur les sur laaprèsastride en fait
puisqueon voit que vous êtes pour
certains d'entre vous pour beaucoup
d'entre vous inspirés par les travaux
d'astr de voir
euh tu dis des enfants
d'astride euh est-ce que j'entends est à
la fois extrêmement enthousiasm puisque
vous êtes dites finalement on s'appuie
sur les travaux et on connaît l'histoire
de de phéniix super Phénix dont on peut
commenter les raisons pour lesquelles on
a mis fin à cette à cette belle aventure
des RNR dans les années 90 euh ma
question c'est est-ce que vous
considérez que finalement cette décision
d'arrêter à au cœur de l'été 2019 à à
n'a pas freiné parce que si je vous
comprends bien elle n'a pas mis fin à à
cette aventure elle n'a pas mis fin à
des possibilités d'avoir des des
réacteurs à neutron rapide on est plutôt
sur des sur des petits modèles vous
concernant évidemment c'est peut-être la
une question de la taille de
dimensionnement de la puissance mais ce
que je ce que j'entends vous annoncz des
délais relativement courts 2030 2035
pour avoir non pas des prototype mais
mais quelque chose de déjà industriel
euh et ça alors ça m'étonne dans dans le
bon sens du terme est-ce que vous vous
pouvez préciser les choses à ce
niveau-là merci donc je vous propose de
répondre très succintement une minute
par représentant en choisissant
peut-être de pas prendre toutes les
questions mais celles qui vous
permettent alors fermeture du cycle en
fait à partir du moment où vous parlez
de réacteur à neutron rapide tout ce qui
a été dit par tous s'applique à tous
donc on va tous recycler le pu le cas
échéant le plutonium pardon le cas
échéant à un moment si on décide brûler
un ou des actin mineurs le vrai point
commun c'est neutron rapide premièrement
deuxièmement monsieur le député ici on
va pas utiliser de
MOX et les MOX que mes collègues vont
probablement utiliser c'est du MOX
rapide donc ça n'est pas directement le
même type de MOX que pour sueli des
réacteurs haau légères dernière chose
Monsieur le Sénateur Astrid alors moi je
suis de ceux qui pensent pour avoir eu
les pieds les mains dedans que il n'y a
pas à terme de nucléaire durable sans
réacteur à neutron rapide
ceci étant le fait que vous ayez ici des
entités qui se remettent en selle sur
les rapides c'est plutôt une excellente
chose je vais choisir sur le le le
niveau de prix parce que c'est capital
c'est la compétitivité d'abord nous
sommes sur un marché international il
faut dézoomer tout de suite il y a une
multiplication de la demande électrique
fois 3 et demi x 4 sur les 30 prochaines
années au niveau mondial ça veut dire
qu'il y a de la place pour tout le monde
maintenant le prix dépend de quoi oui le
prix va être très attractif pour
plusieurs raisons la première c'est que
vous avez un un niveau de sûreté passif
très élevé avec la 4e génération
particulièrement avec les selles fondues
et ça c'est un impact direct sur le coût
du CAPEC c'est les coûts
d'investissement directement la deuxième
c'est dans le business model nous nous
sommes un exploitant nous sommes
concepteur fabricant exploitant
mainteneur c'est le business model qui
est utilisé par la France sur des tas de
secteurs où elle est numéro 1 mondial le
secteur du transport ferroviaire le
secteur de l'eau je vient du secteur de
l'eau je peux vous dire que ce des
déchets du traitement des déchets c'est
un c'est un business model qui permet
d'atte at des niveaux de compétitivité
inégalés jusqu'à présent donc oui nous
serons plus compétitifs que les énergies
fossiles et que les
merci concernant la loi d'accélération
sur le nucléaire ce qu'on considère
intéressant et sur lequel il va falloir
retravailler encore plus en détail c'est
la question de l'installation des
nouveaux réacteurs sur des sites sur des
INB ou sur des nouveaux sites nucléaire
pour ça on considère qu'il y a un vrai
travail à mener ensemble avec l'État sur
descis Dison qui relève de la
planification pourquoi ce type de projet
ce réacteur sur ce site pour quel besoin
par rapport à quelle spécificité de ce
réacteur sur tel site avec quelle
spécificité ça c'est un enjeu clé
concernant l'exploitation aujourd'hui
exana ne se revendique pas exploitant et
collabor activement avec ses partenaires
dont EDF sur le sur le sujet concernant
l'aventure post Astride très clairement
aujourd'hui on se positionne dans une
stratégie de cap capalisation sur les
acquis du passé c'estàd que on a des
forces on a eu peut-être des
déceptions peut-être aujourd'hui très
clairement on s'oriente vers le futur on
capitalise sur le passé au service du
futur ça c'est une évidence l'étape de
passé sur une stratégie SMR Amr pour
exana c'est potentiellement une étape
clé pour parvenir à avancer sur des
stratégies de réacteur de puissance à
bien considérer je laisse Paul sur les
questions supply ch ouais pour aussi sur
sur Astride l'uranium a fait x 4 depuis
l'arrêt d'astride donc quelque chose
qu'on estimait deuxème partie du siècle
en train d'arriver plus vite parce que
la Chine va construire des centaines de
gigw de nucléaire et cetera donc
effectivement il y a des choses qui ont
changé aussi depuis 2009 2019 aussi et
qui rappelle un peu l'urgence de
réinvestir dans le RNR et sur la
question intéressante de de de la
fabrication et des usines nous le
réacteur sodium on s'appuie sur un
écosystème qui est encore existant
notamment un industriel Framatome qui a
encore des usines pour fabriquer des
échangeurs des pompes des cuves et donc
ça ça c'est existant on s'appuie
là-dessus et rappelez aussi que pour le
RNR on est sur des concepts sans
pression donc on n pas en concurrence
aussi avec la Supply chaîne des REP qui
ont besoin de la forge du creusau de des
de gros forgés on est plutôt sur de la
chaudrunnerie des choses mécano soudées
donc c'est c'est une autre supply chaîn
qui est très complémentaire des REP et
qui est qui n'a qu'à être réactivé
quelque part très bien
merci
qu'on est des enfants d'astride ça ça ça
rappelle quelque chose d'important c'est
les
compétences c'est très important d'avoir
une approche industrielle de long terme
et en fait les compétences qui ont été
développées sur as servent à d'autres
projets comme on peut voir ici c'est moi
je j'aimis les j'aimis
le la proposition de de créer une école
des
RNR
pour pour que les les compétences les
jeunes qui arrive sur le marché soit
aussi formé sur les réacteurs euh
rapides
merci peut-être en conclusion et en
complément de ce qui a été dit euh à
quoi nous adhérons complètement le
business model de de nucléo est basé sur
à la fois un un modèle de d'exploitation
des réacteurs c'est-à-dire que sur en
particulier sur le sol français c'est
c'est notre intention évidemment euh
très probablement collabor collaboration
étroite avec avec explooitant historique
et EDF euh je l'ai dit on s'inscrit dans
un écosystème existant avec les les
acteurs historiques la Supply
Chain toujours compétente en parti et le
développement des des compétences
manquantes industrielles que l'on va
également s'atteler à financer euh et un
deuxième modèle qui est le modèle du de
la licence plutôt applicable avec nos
clients internationaux avec certains
pour lesquels on est déjà en contact et
où on essaiera aussi de faire valoir la
Supply Chain que l'on aura développer
pour les composants principaux des des
des installations que l'on que l'on
placera sous licence très bien je vous
remercie merci pour votre concision et
pour ce marathon qui était presque un un
sprint en fait j'espère que on a pu
répondre aux questions des collègues je
vais en profiter pour redonner la main à
mon collègue Stéphane piénoir avec 5
petites minutes de retard merci encore à
vous de vous être soumis à cette
exercice je remercie je félicite Olga
giver pour avoir à la fois présider
cette première table ronde et avoir un
un œil sur le chronomètre en permanence
vous l'avez compris je sais que les les
sujets sont sont sous-jacents sont
nombreux et qu'on pourrait prolonger les
débats mais on a fait le choix aussi de
rassembler des start-up qui sont sur une
technologie qui est pas identique
évidemment mais qui se rejoint par bien
des aspects donc ce nous permet de de
concentrer un peu les les propos nous
allons pouvoir passer à avant d'aborder
la deuxème table ronde à euh ce ce trait
d'union que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
avec
le le nucléaire Vallé qui est un pôle de
compétitivité et vous savez que
l'innovation dans dans le domaine
nucléaire ne concerne pas donc la
technologie des RNR qu'on a que nous
venons d'évoquer elle porte aussi sur la
technologie actuellement la plus
répondue hein les réacteurs à eau
pressurisé qui constituent l'intégralité
de de notre parc actuel ainsi que la la
majorité des réacteurs à travers le
monde donc pour avant d'aborder cette
Inov ces innovations dans sur les REP je
vais passer les la parole à nucléire
Valley avec qui est représenté
aujourd'hui par son directeur général
donc Jean-François Debost et son
directeur technique romain Monier qui
vont donc faire cette transition entre
les les les tables rondes pour évoquer
les enjeux communs aux ZES aux jeunes
entreprises du secteur nucléaire
messieur la parole est à vous monsieur
le Président Madame la rapporteur
monsieurs Mesdames et Messieurs les les
parlementaires je tiens au nom du pôul à
vous remercier pour cette invitation à
cette audition alors tout d'abord
quelques mots sur notre association nous
avons été créés en 2005 sous l'égite du
ministre Besson qui souhaitait relancer
l'innovation dans les territoires à à
Chalon sursone qui héberge toujours
notre notre notre siège nous avons été
relabilisé pôle de compétitivité en
avril de cette année par la première
ministre pour une durée de 4 années
supplémentaires la mission première d'un
pôle de compétitivité donc la nôtre est
de faire émerger des solutions
d'innovation notamment auprès des
petites et moyennes entreprises au sein
des territoires que vous que vous
représentez on fédère aujourd'hui une
communauté de 430 adhérents auxquels il
faut rajouter environ 400 entreprises de
plus qui par qui bien que nétons pas
adhérent à l'association participe à nos
travaux nous comptons 56 % de PME
TPE basé dans tous les bassins he tous
les territoires que vous représentez ici
et nous comptons je dirais également une
trentaine de start-up dont 15 ont déposé
un dossier à la AP réacteur innovant de
France 2030 nous avons en visibilité
l'ensemble des initiatives françaises
qui ont déposé à cet appel d'offre nous
sommes confinancés aujourd'hui par deux
ministères euh Bercy qui est le
fournisseur je dirais le le le financeur
historique des pôles le ministère de la
Défense pour la partie propulsion
nucléaire puisque oui nous avons déjà
des petits réacteurs dans la flotte le
premier petit réacteur a été embarqué
sur le redoutable en 1971 donc nous
avons nous maîtrisons déjà d'ors et déjà
en France un certain nombre de de
technologies nous sommes également
financés par deux Conseils Régionaux la
bourgonne francheconté l'overn ronalpe
et deux intercommunalités le Grand
Chalon et et la communauté du du croosau
Montceau ce soutien public représente
environ un tiers de nos de nos
ressources alors nos missions sont
conventionnées avec les pouvoir public
que je viens de vous vous citer elle
s'articule autour de quatre offes de
service quatre axes euh l'émergence de
solutions innovantes romain Monier notre
directeur technique qui reviendra par
par la suite l'animation économique pour
aider justement ces petites et moyennes
entreprises à croître à créer de
l'emploi au au sein de nos nos
territoires l'accompagnement la levée de
fond et ça c'est un enjeu clé notamment
dans le cadre de l'appel à projet
réacteur innovant
euh puisque nous fédérons aujourd'hui au
travers de notre club investisseur
nctech 15 fonds d'investissement
français dont deux fonds souverains le
fond fond souverain France nucléaire qui
est un je dirais un bras de levier très
important pour la filière nucléaire
française doté de 200 millions d'euros
le fond d'f invvest pour la partie
défense et des families office et des
des Privat banking et puis enfin
l'emploi compétence qui est aussi un
enjeu important pour la filière
nucléaire française et donc donc nous
menons un certain nombre d'actions en
soutien des actions de l'Université des
métiers du
nucléaire dans le cadre du premier
objectif de France 2030 donc qui nous
réunit aujourd'hui nous accompagnons 11
des 15 initiativ qui ont déposé un un
projet je passe la parole à Romain Mony
qui va vous en dire un peu plus oui
alors sur la bonjour à tous sur la
partie accompagnement à l'innovation
notre rôle est d'intervenir à n'importe
quel moment de niveau de maturité du
projet de nos adhérents donc en en
partant de de l'idéation dans nos
domaines d'activité stratégique en
facilitant la la formation des
consortiums en assistant les consortiats
à construire leur projets et enfin en
labellisant leur projet par en le
faisant expertiser et labelliser par
notre conseil
scientifique dans le cadre de l'appel à
projet France 2030 réacteur innovant on
est dans un cas un petit peu particulier
où notre conseil scientifique ne va pas
venir se substituer l'expertise du CEA
mais va venir expertiser des briques
technologiques constitutrices du projet
qui auront alors parfois label ou pas de
label mais qui présente la qualité d' de
pouvoir être transverse entre les
projets et parfois même transverse
jusqu'à apporter au réacteurs à eau
préciurisé donc ces initiatives on les
accompagne également à la recherche de
leur futur partenairire industriel tout
simplement pour qu'ils puissent
commencer à construire leur Supply Chain
comme vous en avez parlé précédemment
mais également pour intégrer dès la
conception des des design les
contraintes les contraintes
technologiques et donc on était là pour
faire la transition je vais faire la
transition vers les les réacteurs ào il
faut pas non plus oublier que notre rôle
c'est d'accompagner l'ensemble de nos
adhérents et donc d'accompagner aussi
nos adhérents sur les guichets de
financement un peu plus classique pour
des des applications REP avec du idmo du
idmo région ou des projets d'innovation
régionaux et enfin un un dernier axe à
ne surtout pas oublier c'est qu'on sort
quand même d'un appel d'un gros appel à
projet France
2030 avec une avec un volet nucléaire
dans lequel 67 projets ont été lauréa
pour pour la partie nucléaire ce qui
représente 343 millions d'euros
d'investissement et qui devrait répondre
à aux enjeux du parc voilà je vous
remercie
merci Monsieur pour pour ces éléments de
de précision et ces éclairage nous
allons donc passer à à ces innovations
sur sur les REP comme comme je
l'évoquais et nous allons commencer par
entendre Olivier bar qui est délégué
général du du jfen du groupement des
industriels français de de l'énergie
nucléaire qui fédère depuis 2018
maintenant quelques 400 entreprises qui
cou ouvre tous les types d'activités
industrielles et tous les domaines de la
production d'électricité d'origine
nucléaire avec les mêmes contraintes
horaire et de timing je passe donc la
parole à Monsieur
bar monsieur le Président merci beaucoup
madame la rapporteur mesdames et
Messieurs les parlementaires je tiens à
vous remercier d'avoir convié le le
gifen à cette audition sur sur
l'innovation dans le domaine nucléaire
euh avant de vous préciser peut-être les
actions sur l'innovation quelques mots
de d'introduction ou de présentation de
cette de cette structure de cet acteur
qui comme vous l'avez dit monsieur le
Président est récent dans le paysage
puisque il a été créé en 2018 afin de
doter la filière d'une organisation qui
est conçue sur le modèle de ses
homologues dans d'autres filière on
pense en particulier à l'aéronautique
avec le GIFAS en regroupant un certain
nombre de d'organisations qui qui
existaient ce qui veut dire que par
construction nous coopérons très
étroitement avec les les acteurs
préexistants à commencé par nucléire
Vallé qui est le de
compétitivité de de la filière nucléaire
à ce jour le gifen et donc ça croit vite
puisque vous étiez resté sur 400 on a
aujourd'hui 400 500
membres et ça et et ça se poursuit
évidemment bon avec 500 membres en
réalité on a à peu près l'ensemble des
entreprises qui représentent l'essentiel
de l'activité en volume et des emplois
de la filière he plus de 90 % donc ça
veut dire que on a aujourd'hui la
Constitution la représentation pour
travailler parmi elles il y a les
exploitants EDF CEA aano andra Framatome
mais aussi les fournisseurs de tourant
ETI PME beaucoup de petites entreprises
et des organisations professionnelles
des associations professionnelles qui
travaillent avec nous comme fr France
chaudonnerie Satec ingénierie et et
autres donc c'est un un rôle de de
fédération d'une filière qui représente
un peu plus de 200000 emplois et dans
lesquels les entreprises sont euh très
présentes à l'export à 50 % d'entre
elles et à 80 % d'entre elles
travaillent pour d'autres secteurs que
le nucléaire donc ça aussi sont des axes
de coopération le gifen a a trois
missions auxqueles l'innovation
contribue toutes trois la première c'est
de fédérer la filière pour sa
mobilisation et sa performance
collective c'est de fournir des services
d'intérêt commun aux entreprises essayer
de représenter la filière auprès de ces
parties prenantes telleles que les
pouvoirs publics aujourd'hui ou les
médias ou ou ou autres interlocuteurs y
compris sur la scène européenne ou
internationale afin de répondre à à ces
missions le chifen organise ses travaux
autour de différents axes de travail sur
les compétences et la formation sur la
sûreté la qualité développement
international la transformation
numérique les affaires européennes et la
communication et et à tout cela les
activités de de Red d'innovation
contribu le gifen s'est attaché d'abord
à travailler sur les compétences et sur
les capacités industrielles qui sont une
condition nécessaire pour tous les
projets qu'on est en train d'évoquer là
et on a remis récemment les résultats du
programme match qui visait précisément à
doter la filière d'un outil structuré et
collaboratif pour prévoir les besoins en
compétences et piloter la mise en
adéquation de la mobilisation de la
filière c'est ce programme qui a permis
de doter la filière d'une vision à 10
ans et d'identifier un besoin qui a été
estimé à alors
60000 emplois équivalent temp plein sur
le périmètre qu'on avait étudié c'est le
cœur de la filière extrapolé au 200000
emplois que j'évoqué tout à l'heure de
l'ordre de 100000 besoins en emploi sur
les 10 ans qui viennent alors je tiens à
préciser
que cette estimation s'entend hors
productivité et et le programme match
nous a permis précisément au-delà de
l'estimation de travailler sur des
actions sur des leviers d'action pour
conduire cette mise en adéquation donc à
la fois en terme de développement de
ressources de mobilisation mais aussi en
terme de renforcement de performance
opérationnelle et de soutenabilité
économique et financière de la filière
les résultats de ce programme permettent
aux entreprises de préparer les plans de
recrutement d'investissement qu'
qu'elles pourront engager quand le
nouveau programme nucléaire sera
effectivement lancé c'est un programme
qui mettra à jour ses résultats chaque
année à partir de
2024 afin d'intégrer l'évolution des
plans de charge en particulier ceux des
projets de SMR et d'Amr qui devront être
ajoutés au périmètres qu'on a étudié
jusqu'ici de mesurer la dynamique de
mobilisation et d'ajuster les actions de
de la filière alors en vous expliquant
ça en fait je suis déjà dans le sujet de
l'innovation puisque le le gifen porté
quelque part une démarche innovante que
nous commençons à partager avec les
autres avec les autres filières et on
voit que l'innovation est bien porté par
la dynamique
industrielle qui qui nous anime
concernant les actions d'innovation plus
généralement dans la filière elles ont
vocation donc à irriguer tous les enjeux
et et toutes les actions de la dynamique
industrielle qui s'engage elles sont
nécessaires pour optimiser les gains
d'amélioration de performance que l'on
pourra attendre de l'enchaînement des
projets et c'est un véritable programme
industriel qui qui perf permet à la fois
d'améliorer l'efficacité avec laquelle
on réplique d'un projet à l'autre et
d'optimiser les modes d'exécution en
introduisant des innovations c'est ce
qui permettra de gagner sur la vitesse
de construction des réacteurs par
exemple et pour favoriser l'émergence de
ces innovations au service de la
performance de la filière nucléaire le
gifen a mis en place et pilote en
coopération très étroite avec le pôle de
compétitivité nucléaire vallée une
commission Recherche et Développement
Innovation au sein de laquelle les
entreprises euh se réunissent euh
mensuellement et euh et travaillent sur
des sujets d'innovation euh
commun euh ce cadre en fait permet euh
essentiellement aux petites entreprises
de de trouver les moyens de coopérer sur
des sujets sur lesquels elle ne pourrait
pas euh travailler seul euh une feuille
de route a été établie pour la période
2327 et on trouve là des des des sujets
je dirais transverses d'intérêt
transverse pour la filière comme dans le
cyle de l'eau ou dans les nouveaux
combustibles on en a parlé ou dans les
valorisation des matières et dans le
dans le transformation numérique le
développement de de l' de l'intelligence
artificielle dans les dans les
différents procédés ou ou ou encore la
fabrication additive qui pourrait
bouleverser la la fabrication de de
pièces mécaniques si si on arrive à
aller au bout de l'industrialisation de
ces de ces pistes voilà en conclusion je
tiens juste à à souligner à quel point
l'innovation est partout finalement elle
irrigue tous les efforts de la filière
au moment où on comprend qu'on est très
attendu en terme de mobilisation et
d'efficacité
elle va de l'émergence de solutions
totalement innovante jusqu'à la
nécessaire démarch industriell
d'améliorationue dans un j'ai envie de
dire dans un subtil équilibre entre de
la réplication industrielle pour pas
réinventer toujours la manière de faire
mais aussi l'injection de nouvelles de
nouveaux procéder de nouvelles manières
de faire pour incrémentalement améliorer
la performance et c'est bien ce que l'on
a l'intention de porter sur les 10 ans
les 20 ans qui viennent avec la relance
du nucléaire je vous remercie
beaucoup merci euh merci Monsieur à
présent je vais je vais donner la parole
à à Bernard Salah alors qui est
directeur technique groupe et directeur
de la Red de DF que certain d'entre nous
connaissent bien que je vais d'abord
remercier pour avoir bien voulu
bouleverser un tout petit petit peu son
agenda et être parmi nous aujourd'hui
parce que c'était c'était pas gagner
d'avance c'était pas çale donc merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté d'être en
présentiel pour cette présentation la
contribution deedf est évidemment
importante dans le contexte français que
que nous connaissons et donc je je vous
laisse la parole monsieur Salah merci
merci Monsieur le monsieur le Président
euh Mesdames et Messieurs les les
députés et sénateurs alors j'avais prévu
de de vous présenter quelques le slide
mais je pense pour gagner du temps je
propose de ne montrer que le dernier que
la conclusion et je vais vous vous
commenter cette cette conclusion alors
l'innovation comme vous l'avez dit
monsieur le Président concerne aussi les
réacteurs à haut pressurisé euh la
meilleure preuve et c'est le le premier
point de cette conclusion c'est que nous
maintenons côté
EDF nos réacteurs réacteurs existants et
aussi réacteurs futurs que nous
envisageons que ça soit les op 2 ou les
newward au meilleur niveau des
technologies disponibles on peut
l'illustrer de façon simple vous
trouverez tout ça dans les dans les
slides sur le parc existant aujourd'hui
le niveau de sûreté que nous sommes en
train de mettre en œuvre sur nos REP les
4è décennales du palier 900 sont basés
sur une référence
EP et donc notre enjeu et nous avons
déjà réalisé ça sur plusieurs réacteurs
c'est de de mettre en œuvre des
modifications permis par l'innovation
pour faire en sorte que ces réacteurs
existants soient au même niveau que les
pr le deuxième volet sur les gros
réacteurs c'est le PR2 le PR2 comme vous
le savez tient compte également du
retour d'expérience du premier réacteur
pr que nous avons réalisé flamandville
et tient compte également de toutes les
innovations notamment en matière de
rapidité de de construction de façon à
être mieux maîtrisé je dirais en terme
de de
délai la deuxième grande idée et ce sont
les les alinéas 2 3 et et 4 de de cette
conclusion c'est que le processus
d'innovation dans les reps est un
processus
évolutionnaire alors nous sommes là
aussi très proches d'autres filières
donc je citerai l'aéronautique où
lorsque vous regardez la démarche des à
320 à 350 à 34 80 qui s'est qui s'est
instauré cette innovation se fait par
Brig technologique alors qu'est-ce que
c'est des des briques technologiques en
fait ce sont des des éléments techniques
qui permettent d'améliorer la
performance en venant se caser comme une
brique finalement dans la conception
d'un réacteur là aussi vous trouverez ça
en détail dans les slides qui vous ont
été transmis je citerai par exemple le
le digital he le le numérique donc on
développ aujourd'hui des outils pour
fiabiliser les plannings d'arrêt de nos
de nos réacteurs faisons appel donc aux
meilleures techniques disponibles
d'intelligence artificielle pour piloter
l'avancement et la qualité de
construction des des chantiers neufs
pour gérer les aléas et aussi pour
exploiter toute notre toute notre
documentation existante qui est qui est
ancienne et que nous avons complètement
numérisé et mis au standards les plus
modernes
autre exemple de brique technologique la
fabrication additive donc nous sommes
aujourd'hui en train d'expérimenter les
différentses technologies de fabrication
additive nous avons déjà des premiers
succès dans l'hydraulique et nous
transférons ces succès de l'hydraulique
donc au niveau du nucléaire grâce aussi
là au soutien qui nous a été apporté au
titre de France relance qui nous a
permis de lancer plusieurs projets vous
trouverez dans les dans les transparents
le projet arcane fédérant plus plusurs
acteurs qui permet de tester et de
d'expérimenter ces solutions s'agissant
du combustible le combustible est aussi
une brique technologique d'innovation
nous visons à développer alors
excusez-moi du jargon des n accident
tolerant fuel donc des des combustibles
plus tolérants aux accidents avec des
gainages de de chrome notamment sur les
gaines combustibles donc ça aussi
quelque chose que nous comptons mettre
en œuvre et s'agissant du cycle du du
combustible que que vous regardez de
très près monsieur le Président nous
regardons aussi la question du
multirecyclage en Rep en Rep donc visant
à maîtriser les quantités de plutonium
qui tournent dans le dans nos réacteurs
de façon globale donc c'est aussi une
innovation majeure complexe mais sur
lequel nous travaillons avec l'ensemble
de nos partenaires et je n'oublie pas
dans l'ensemble de ces briques
technologiques également le volet
environnement nous sommes aujourd'hui en
train de tester des innovations visant à
limiter la consommation d'eau de nos
réacteurs dans leur Tours
d'aéroréfrigérant vous voyez les grandes
tours par lesquell on refroidit nos
réacteurs donc nous visons à limiter les
consommation d'eau nous sommes en train
de tester sur le site du budget dans un
ban d'expérimentation qui s'appelle
Mistral un processus venant d'une
start-up alors au demeurant américaine
et que nous pourrions déployer voilà
voilà donc voilà sur sur ces briques
technologiques s'agissant des s'agissant
des SMR alors il y a aussi des SMR au
pressurisé mon mon collègue Frédéric
Hoffman vous vous présentera le projet
newward je pourrais citer aussi des
réacteur qui produisent de la chaleur
donc un acteur qui s'appelle calogena
par exemple que nous avons aussi soutenu
donc qui vise à produire de la chaleur
pour des réseaux de chaleur il y a
également de nombreux projets européens
en la matière notamment Finlande par
exemple pour produire de la chaleur pour
faire également de la désalinisation et
évidemment nos collègues américains ont
également développer de nombreux
réacteurs à eau pressurisé ou à eau
bouillante donc basé sur des
technologies existantes vous avez évoqué
le projet new scale qui est
effectivement arrêté mais on peut citer
aussi le projet de General Electric qui
s'appelle le
bwrx300 dont nos collègues canadiens
d'Ontario power generation envisagent
donc une première mise en service avant
2030 l'intérêt des projets REP en fait
est est double c'est d'utiliser une
technologie donc qui a fait ses preuves
qui est qui est bien connue c'est un
atout effectivement majeur en terme de
conception de construction et d'analyse
de sûreté on est dans un cadre qui est
habituel si je puis dire et c'est aussi
point très très important comme le
montre la discussion précédente ce sont
des réacteurs qui utilisent des
combustibles connus
et qui sont d'ors et déjà quasiment
disponibles dans des usines existantes
ils sont en général simplement plus
courts ce qui n'est pas le le cas
évidemment de réacteurs plus plus
innovants de type de type génération
génération
4 nous pensons que ces smmr àut
pressurisé ont une ont une probabilité
raisonnable de produire donc de
l'électricité autour des années 2030
nous sommes aussi je le dis en passant
extrêmement intéressés par la démarche
de de nos collègues sur les sur les Amr
du fait du
dynamisme extrêmement fort
entrepreneurial qui est qui est porté
nous la regardons de très très près avec
des liens comme ça a été indiqué très
fort pratiquement avec l'ensemble
d'entre eux il n'en demeure pas moins
que ce sont des démarches de start-up et
donc forcément aussi avec des risques
plus élevés pour conclure je dirais que
les démarches
aupressurisé SMR Amr brique
technologique sont des démarches en fait
qu' ne faut pas opposé mais qui
s'enrichissent globalement entre elles
je vous
remercie merci pour cet
enrichissement Sal et cette présentation
je vais passer avant d'aborder les les
les questions passer la parole à votre
voisin qui est un
voisin physique mais aussi un voisin un
allié tête du programme nward monsieur
Hoffman qui est directeur du programme
newward piloté notamment par EDF et donc
nous allons vous écouter pour les
innovations de de ce programme les les
les les perspectives puisque nous
mettons évidemment pays mais beaucoup
d'espoir dans cette technologie
particulière c'est à vous monsieur
Hoffman merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les les
parlementaires mesdames et messieurs
bonjour oui en fait je suis en charge du
du programme SMR France et
principalement donc à EDF et en charge
du développement du du newir des smmr
merci de me donner l'opportunité euh de
présenter newward et et ses innovations
euh newward est un produit le produit le
plus avancé aujourd'hui en en France il
est placé et porté par par EDF avec le
concours de l'ensemble de de la filière
nucléaire française donc avec le CEA
technique atome naval group Framatome et
on a été rejoint récemment par un
partenaire européen tracté belle ce
projet est soutenu par par l'état
français avec une un soutien de l'ordre
de de 500 million d'euros au titre de de
France relance et de France
2030 c'est un c'est une Centrale qui
comprend deux deux réacteurs intégrés à
haut
pressurisé qui délivre au total 340 MW
électriques plus de la chaleur j'y
reviendrai derrière il est fondé sur le
savoir-faire et la et l'expérience
française en matière de réacteur
àpressurisé de depuis des décennies et
cette mais cette centrale rassemble de
la hautees technologie et de nombreuses
innovations de rupture que je voulais
parcourir avec vous euh je vais en citer
trois la la première c'est la
construction modulaire alors qui n'est
pas forcément euh limitée enfin qui est
commune à l'ensemble des des smmr donc
en fait le le nuir des smmr sera
préassemblé dans dans des usines qui
produiront des modules donc ça
représente à peu près 70 % du travail
qui est à réaliser pour construire un
newward ensuite ces modules seront
acheminés sur sur le site pour y être
assemblé un peu comme les les Airbus ou
les tronçons sont sont rassemblé et
assemblé et ensuite sous forme
finalement d'un d'un container ils
seront placés et reliés entre eux pour
construire le l'usine alors cela
représente de nombreux avantag notamment
en terme de durée de construction
puisqueaujourd'hui euh on imagine
construire le le nuir des smmr en en 40
mois euh et ça permet également de
réduire à la fois les risques et et les
coûts alors il y a une règle qui qui
existe dans dans dans le monde de de ce
ce type de d'activité c'est la la règle
du 138 où en fait quand on a 1 heure de
travail dans dans une usine en fait
l'équivalent de ce travail làà il faut 3
He s'il faut réaliser ce travail- làà
dans un atelier aux abords du du site et
il faut 8h si on doit le le réaliser sur
le site lui-même donc on voit tout
l'intérêt de de la de la modularité du
du newir des smmr voilà ensuite ça passe
par la création d'un certain nombre
d'usines qui vont fabriquer ces modules
et qui permettra de soutenir euh
finalement la la
réindustrialisation qui nous qui nous
est cher la deuxième innovation c'est la
la chaudière intégrée
donc sur les juste pour rappeler les
choses en fait sur les les réacteurs de
forte puissance le circuit primaire euh
est composé de de de plusieurs de
plusieurs pièces on va dire la première
c'est la cuve qui contient le
combustible et qui est chargé de
chauffer l'eau du circuit primaire la
deuxième partie je dirais c'est le
générateur de vapeur qui qui permet de
de produire de la vapeur d'être turbiné
pour produire de l'électricité et puis
les pompes primaires qui permettent de
prendre c'est l'eau du circuit primaire
de la réinjecter dans dans la cuve et
bien sur le nuir des smmr euh le le
générateur de les générateurs de vapeur
et les pompes primaires sont dans la
cuve donc tout ça est intégré d'où le
nom de de chaudière intégré et qui crée
l'innovation de de nuir
SMR alors cette
cette innovation elle est rendue
possible par un certain nombre d'autres
innovations notamment des générateurs de
vapeur à plaque en Titan sur lesquels on
travaille et qui permettent de rendre
tout ce système beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus compact
euh cette chaudière de par ses
technologies et puis de sa petite taille
présente un certain nombre d'intérêts
sur le plan de de la sûreté notamment un
système de sûreté passive qui répond aux
meilleurs standards internationaux et
euh facilite l'acceptabilité du newir
des SMR à proximité des centres de de
consommation le 3è euh la 3ème
innovation c'est la capacité de
cogénération
euh dans la mesure où en fait le neward
a la possibilité dans sa version
standard euh de euh produire de la
chaleur bacarbone en plus de
l'électricité et donc on a euh on a une
centrale de production qui peut soit
créer 100 % de de son énergie sous forme
d'électricité avec 340 MW
ou utiliser une partie de la chaleur du
du cœur pour la délivrer directement
sous forme de chaleur et être utilisé
par par un un client et dans ce cas on
peut délivrer 100 MW de de chaleur et on
on a encore 310 MW d'électricité donc on
on voit que la totalité du newward en
version cogénération atteint 410 MW de
puissance donc 20 % de plus que dans sa
version son 100 % électrique voilà donc
on voit tout l'intérêt d'avoir de de la
cogénération juste quelques chiffres
aujourd'hui en France on a 45 % de
l'énergie totale qui est consommée
l'énergie finale consommée et correspond
à des à des besoins de chaleur donc ça
représente 700 tawh par an et près de de
60 % de de cette chaleur est est carboné
donc ça veut dire que devant nous on a
environ 400 TWh de chaleur à décarboné
un noir dessmr avec ces 100 ces 100 MW
de de chaleur peut produire 0,8 tarawh
de de chaleur par par an voilà donc ça
ça permet d'ouvrir finalement de
nouvelles opportunités euh
d'utilisation du du neward pour
décarboner un certain nombre d'activités
grâce à cette à cette chaleur bacarbone
alors le dernier point que je voulais
aborder bien c'est finalement
les les innovations qui sont liées aux
usages de cette chaleur aujourd'hui on
est sollicité côté EDF et newward par un
certain nombre d'industriels qui
cherchent à se décarboner et et donc à à
trouvver d'autres manières de de de
répondre à cet enjeu au-delà de de
l'électrification et donc on est en
contact avec des monde industriel des
pétrochimistes des entreprises aussi qui
consomment beaucoup d'énergie les
papetiers les
sucriers on a également le débouché de
l'hydrogène
avec une innovation aussi qui est en
cours de développement sur les
électrolyseurs à haute température qui
permettent d'utiliser à la fois
l'électricité et la chaleur et permettre
de réduire finalement la consommation
d'énergie associée à la production
d'hydrogène et puis au-delà de ça et
bien il y a aussi la chaleur urbaine si
on est à proximité d'un centre urbain
qui a besoin de chaleur bacarbone ou la
désalinisation d'eau de d'eau de mer
voilà les les points que je voulais
partager avec vous sur les innovations
qui finalement se se situe à beaucoup
d'endroits dans dans la la fabrication
la la création et puis l'utilisation du
noir des smmr
merci merci Monsieur Hoffman pour cette
présentation avant de passer à à la
suite de notre de notre programme je
vais passer la parole aux collègues s'il
souhait
poser des questions sur cette deuxème
table ronde sur les innovations en
Rep s'il n'y en a pas pour l'in oui
Monsieur
L merci beaucoup j'ai une question sur
le newward et et après peut-être plus
sur les
PR2 donc si j'ai bien compris la
différence entre le New World et les
smmr présenté précédemment là on utilise
de l'eau pour le refroidissement ça veut
dire est-ce qu'il y a captage et rejet
comme sur un comme sur un gros réacteur
on va dire et deuxème question donc
c'est sur les les PR2 de il me semble
qu' en fait le design n'est pas terminé
donc combien de de milliers d'heures
d'ingénierie il reste pour le finir
est-ce que Framatome ety en capacité de
produire en série les pièces maîtresses
moi j'avais posé la question au
président au PDG de Framatome il y a un
an il disait qu'effectivement sur le
couvercle on nétait pas prêt euh et euh
le la loi qui a été adoptée cette année
parle de six nouveaux PR2 peut-être
peut-être plus euh là aussi le PDG dEDF
Monsieur Raymond c'était déjà lui je
crois m'avait dit qui l'avait signé pour
6 pas d'avantage alors est-ce qu'on peut
en savoir plus là-dessus
merci alors sur la consommation d'eau
effectivement il y a de l'eau dans le
circuit primaire mais cette eau elle
elle circule donc une fois qu'on a
alimenté le circuit il y a plus il n'y a
plus de de consommation d'eau là où il y
a une consommation d'eau c'est dans le
la production de d'électricité
puisque'en fait il faut créer le vide
dans à l'aval des des turbines et et
c'est ça qui finalement consomme de
l'eau si on on évapore l'eau pour pour
refroidir après on peut aussi utiliser
un circuit on appelle un circuit ouvert
qui va prélever l'eau dans la rivière la
réchauffer et la restituer à l'aval mais
dans ce cas-là on n pas de on a pas de
consommation d'eau on a juste une
augmentation de température de l'eau de
la
rivière s'agissant de s'agissant des pr
enfin de l'pr2 en particulier le niveau
de de design enfin pardon de de
conception est en fait beaucoup beaucoup
plus avancé que tous les réacteurs dont
on a on a évoqué donc on est aujourd'hui
en train de préparer le le design
détaillé donc cette conception détaillée
n'est n'est pas encore terminée mais l'
est temp mais est temps court mais ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que le
niveau de détail dans lequel on est est
beaucoup plus fin que pour les autres
réacteurs y compris le le projet newart
s'agissant du nombre de réacteurs donc
aujourd'hui nous nous regardons le la
perspective effectivement de six
réacteurs bon mais ont été aussi annoncé
des perspectives de H supplémentaires on
est aujourd'hui sur les six
premiers si je peux ajouter un point
là-dessus euh du point de vue de
Industri ri donc de l'ensemble de la
filière et des entreprises le signal
dont les entreprises ont
besoin c'est c'est de se mobiliser sur
sur une cadence en fait le 6 + 8 en fait
c'est surtout un programme pour se
lancer dans une série qui permet de
reconstituer la capacité à tenir une
cadence au bon niveau de performance le
8 il correspond à une cadence de un
réacteur par an en France c'est c'est à
ça que ça correspond il faut c'est
important de réfléchir en cadence si on
veut voir la chose de industrielle pour
se donner les les les les les conditions
pour remplir les conditions de la de la
du succès d'un tel
programme merci j'avais à titre
personnel quelques questions vous l'avez
dit on est les uns et les autre dans une
compétition internationale avec des
besoins
d'électricité qui sont sur une
croissance extrêmement forte c'est déjà
ces dernières années et probablement les
années à venir dans cette compétition
internationale
plusieurs sujets d'abord comment nous
situons-nous au niveau français quels
sont les les éventuels conséquence de de
l'arrêt de l'abandon de du projet de de
start-up américaine nkel est-ce que ça a
un impact est-ce que vous considérer que
ça peut avoir un impact sur le le projet
newward en particulier et puis donc en
terme de concurrence internationale par
rapport aux autres projets de de
développement que nous connaissons je
fais référence à Itachi au projet Itachi
et et
Rolls-Royce voilà comment dans cette
course à internationale comment nous n
nous situons-nous c'est un peu aussi une
question d'une d'un d'un internaute une
question d'un internaute qui nous qui
nous interroge sur cette course contre
la monte engagé à l'échelle
internationale c'est une question qu'on
aurait pu poser évidemment pour les RNR
sur la filière RNR tout à l'heure mais
évidemment nous sommes soucieux on sait
à quel point ça ça va très vite on a
déjà 25 % de de de croissance sur le
gifen en en l'espace d'une note en terme
d'adhérent don on on voit tout ça très
vite et j'ai une dernière question qui
n'a rien à voir avec ce que je viens
d'évoquer c'est la possibilité qui
existe et qui est pratiquée je crois en
en Finlande donc la possibilité
d'augmenter la puissance d'un réacteur
existant donc là on est sur de sur du
REP traditionnel on n'est pas sur du SMR
porté de de 900 MW à 1300 MW certains
réacteurs euh est-ce que c'est
envisageable c'était
en par c'éit évidemment
inenvisageable l'hiver dernier où on
avait une bonne partie du parc qui était
inopérant pour des tas de raison est-ce
que désormais lorsque nous sommes dans
une situation un peu plus confortable on
peut envisager de de mettre à l'arrêt un
réacteur pour le augmenter sa puissance
donc de 900 à à 1300
MW je vais essayer d'apporter quelques
quelques éléments pour pour F s'agissant
de la la concurrence internationale donc
elle est elle est effectivement forte
j'ai j'ai cité plusieurs projets
américains
notamment ce que je voudrais dire aussi
c'est que le le volume et je crois que
ça a été dit très bien par Jean-Luc
Alexandre le le volume
d'électricité à
produire ici même en Europe dans l'Union
européenne est est absolument
considérable si on y rajoute les
questions d'hydrogène ça rajoute encore
des choses la chaleur ça rajoute encore
des choses et d'une certaine façon il y
a de la place pour plusieurs acteurs
donc l'enjeu c'est plutôt le démarrage
de ces projets SMR aujourd'hui il n'y a
aucune construction qui ne sont faite
donc aujourd'hui le marché est à
construire puisqueaucune construction
n'est faite par contre si le marché
démarre il y a vraiment
énormément de place en la matière je
signale une une initiative qui a été
prise au niveau européen qui s'appelle
iu partnership partenariat
européen sur les smmr qui a été reconnu
aussi par le la commission lors de de sa
séance à de de Bratislava début début
novembre qui montre l'intérêt de
développer en fait les conditions
permettant le déploiement de SMR en
Europe la France est très bien doté euh
mes voisins sont je pense le le
témoignage hein
230000 salariés de la filière nucléaire
en France sur tout le secteur d'activité
de la recherche jusqu'à la construction
conception exploitation donc il est très
très clair que nous avons beaucoup
beaucoup d'atouts à la fois sur les
réacteurs existants mais les réacteurs
nouveaux aussi qui montrent un vrai
dynamisme majeur en la matière sur votre
dernière question monsieur le Président
propos d'augmentation de la puissance
alors on peut augmenter effectivement la
puissance des REP mais on ne peut pas
l'augmenter de beaucoup on peut
l'augmenter de quelques de quelques
pourcent il y a deux façons d'augmenter
il y a essayé d'augmenter le rendement
de la partie secondaire de
l'installation donc la turbine donc
c'est ce que nous pourrions faire sur
nos réacteurs 900 MW et il y a une
partie qui est un peu plus sophistiquée
qui consiste à augmenter la puissance du
réacteur lui-même donc de tirer un
meilleur profit du réacteur faut
augmenter un petit peu la température
c'est un peu plus sophistiqué c'est
quelques pourcent aussi donc passer
transformer un réacteur 900 MW en
réacteur 1300 MW donc là la réponse est
clairement non ça c'est techniquement
pas possible augmenter la puissance de
nos réacteurs de quelques pourcent ça
c'est oui et et on on y travaille
alors quelques précisions monsieur le
sénateur le projet ncale n'est pas
abandonné he il y en reste encore CIN
dans le monde c'est seulement le projet
en Idao qui a été abandonné cette cette
semaine c'est quand même un point un
point important aujourd'hui on compte
dans le monde à peu près 80 projets de
SMR Amr le département d'État américain
a estimé le marché à peu près à horizon
2040 à 180 milliards d'euros donc comp
tenu des besoins en énergie électricité
chaleur effectivement je rejoins tout à
fait les propos je confirme tout à fait
les propos de de Monsieur sal il y a il
y a de la place pour pour tout le monde
on s'aperçoit aujourd'hui en tout cas
sur les 15 initiatives que nous avons en
visibilité qu'elles ont toutes pour les
de tiers d'entre elles intérêt supérieur
à 6 7 donc pas très loin du 9 donc la
marche à monter n'est pas si haute que
ça ça c'est c'est important à à le noter
il est important aussi
euh sur les enjeux d'investissement euh
que le fond enfin la deuxième tranche du
fond France nucléaire soit levée par
l'État puisque nos entreprises nos PME
vont avoir besoin plus jamais de fonds
propres pour pouvoir je dirais continuer
leurs innovations on l'a vu dans France
relance France relance quelques chiffres
c'est plus d'un milliard d'euros de
projets qui ont été déposés au volet
nucléaire 160 projets j'oserait dire
seulement 74 ont ont é retenu puisque il
n'y avait pas suffisamment de
subventions en face c'est 80 entreprises
dont 60 % de PME TPE donc nos PME nos
TPE sont au service de la filière
innovent plus que jamais et ont besoin
plus que jamais du soutien des pouvoirs
publics pour se faire le pôle juste pour
vous donner quelques chiffres les
chiffres sont têtus mais le pôle a
labilisé ces trois dernières années pour
plus de 600 millions d'euros d'assè
budgétaire de projet de RD donc 80 % été
porté par des petites entreprises qui
sont basées sur vos territoire monieurs
mesdames les les sénateurs et et député
donc elles ont plus que jamais besoin de
vot de soutien au service des REP au
service des projets SMR MMR sur lesquel
la France on peut le dire a une vraie
avancée technologique hein
elles ont plus que jamais besoin du
soutien de l'État
voilà je voulais juste je voulais juste
compléter la par rapport à à newcale en
fait le modèle de développement de
newcale est un peu différent en fait ils
ont développé un un design ils l'ont
fait licencier donc donc le le design
est licencié auprès des autorités
américaines et aujourd'hui il cherch un
site pour pour le le construire en fait
et c'est ça la difficulté aussi de de
ces projets c'est qu'à la fois il faut
avoir le design mais aussi un site pour
le le mettre le mettre en place donc
c'est pour ça que newward travaille sur
une tête de série en France pour
démontrer finalement la la crédibilité
développer la crédibilité à la fois
technique et commercial du newward pour
ensuite pouvoir le commercialiser et
développer l'effet de de série
très bien chers collègues s'il n'y a pas
d'autres questions je vous propose de de
de passer à la suite de de notre
programme et pour pour cette suite je
vais redonner la parole à Olga givarnet
pour une une question essentielle
évidemment alors sur on parle beaucoup
d'innovation il y a une question de
certification de ces nouveaux projets
qu'il s'agisse de filières REP ou de de
nouvelles filières type RNR et pour ça
donc Olga va mener les les les débats et
les interventions de l'ASN et de l'IRSN
qui nous font le plaisir d'être parmi
nous également ce
matin merci beaucoup et oui nous allons
terminer ces exposés avec les
interventions de l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire et de l'Institut de radio
prototection et de sûreté nucléaire sur
un sujet stratégique pour l'innovation
dans le domaine nucléaire
l'accompagnement de la certification des
solutions technologiques innovantes en
effet si les grandes entreprises du
secteur nucléaire sont rompues aux
contraintes de certification de leurs
nouveaux projets tel n'est pas le cas
des start-up elle-même soumise à
d'autres contraintes notamment de
financement qui leur impos d'avancer à
un rythme soutenu dans leur
développement et vous en avez fait état
lors de la première table ronde j'ai
d'abord le plaisir de donner la parole
pour 7 minutes au directeur général de
l'ASN Olivier Gupta ainsi qu'à Philippe
Dupuis responsable de la mission
réacteur innovant je vous
remercie très bien madameputé merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président Monsieur
le vice-président madame Mames et
Messieurs les parlementaires mesdames
messieurs euh d'abord je vous remercie
d'avoir invité laasn à s'exprimer sur
sur ce sujet euh vous l'avais signalé je
suis ACC compagné philipuis qui roule
qui joue un rôle absolument central au
sein de laasn sur ce sujet des réacteurs
innovants et que les les porteurs de
projet de ce côté de la table
connaissent bien nous avons été amenés à
évoquer cette question des des petits
réacteurs au cours d'auditions récentes
et je voudrais ici en profiter pour
dissiper toute ambigué
en commençant par rappeler qu'il y a des
principes fondamentaux qui s'appliquent
à l'ensemble des réacteurs qu'ils soit
petit ou gros innovant ou pas et que
l'ASN applique et et fait respecter le
premier d'entre eux c'est la
responsabilité première de l'exploitant
dans le nucléaire il ne suffit pas de
respecter des règles fixées par
l'autorité euh il s'agit d'abord que
l'exploitant euh propose une
installation sûre et apporte la
démonstration qu'elle
l'est deuxè principe c'est c'est
l'exigence d'un haut niveau de
protection des personnes et de
l'environnement à la fois pour ses
réacteurs eux-mêm mais aussi pour les
usin de fabrication et de retraitement
le cas échéant de leur combustible et
pour la gestion des déchets ça a été
assez largement évoqué mais très
clairement il n'y aura pas pour laasn de
compromis sur ce point un haut niveau de
sûreté et troisème principe extrêmement
important c'est celui de la transparence
et je je le signale parce que certains
des nouveaux entrants découvrent qu'il y
a dans le nucléaire des règles de
transparence qui sont bien plus
exigeantes que ce qui se passe dans le
reste de l'industrie et bien sûr pour
nous là non plus pas question de
transiger sur ce point donc voyez des
des principes identiques mais aussi bien
entendu des questions spécifiques que
posent ces réacteurs innovants et qui
appellent des réponses spécifiques et je
voudrais en citer trois sur lesquel jeis
m'attarder la première c'est la question
relative au niveau de sûreté attendu
pour ces réacteurs
innovants la deuxième c'est le souhait
de la plupart des porteurs de projet que
ces réacteurs soient autorisés dans les
mêmes conditions dans plusieurs pays et
et donc ce souhait pose au-delà de la
question de l'harmonisation des règles
de sûeté la question de la
standardisation finalement de
l'acceptation dans plusieurs pays d'un
même modèle et enfin trème question
c'est celle de vous l'évoqueiez madame
la députée c'est celle de l'organisation
d'un dialogue entre d'une part SN et
l'IRSN et d'autre part des porteurs de
projets qui n'ont pas tous la
connaissance de nos exigences de nos
pratiques et qui viennent nous voir à un
stade parfois très préliminaire de la
conception alors sur le niveau de sûreté
attendu je pense que la différence
essentielle entre les les gros réacteurs
et les petits c'est la question du site
d'implantation ça a été assez largement
évoqué ces réacteurs ont vocation à être
implanté le cas échéant sur des sites
industriels donc ce ne sont pas des
sites nucléaires ce sont parfois des
sites qui qui sont beaucoup plus proches
de zones danssément peuplé que ne le
sont les les les gros sites nucléaires
aujourd'hui et donc on peut pas
envisager sur des sites denément peuplé
d'évacuer les populations comme c'est
prévu aujourd'hui dans les plans
d'intervention autour des sites
nucléaires donc ça signifie que les
démonstrations de sûreté de ces
réacteurs doivent porter la preuve que
les rejets restent tout à fait
négligeable alors est-ce que c'est
atteignable la bonne nouvelle c'est que
ces petits réacteurs ont des
caractéristiques favorables de ce point
de
vue qui peuvent effectivement permettre
d'atteindre un tel objectif mais encore
faut-il le démontrer de façon
rigoureuse et et là bien
sûr une des difficultés c'est le peu de
retour d'expérience en tout cas le
moindre retour d'expérience sur ces
technologies que sur les technologies à
Ha souspression donc il y aura des
démonstrations à apporter probablement
aussi de la recherche et développement à
faire je pense que l'IRSN aura
l'occasion d'en d'en parler en tout cas
c'est c'est un point de vigilance pour
pour
nous voilà donc en tout état de cause
deux conditions au plan de la sûreté la
réduction par rapport au gros réacteur
des conséquences des accidents à du
proportion si je puis dire de la
proximité de de de ces petits réacteurs
par rapport au aux zones d'ement peuplé
et la rigueur des démonstrations qui qui
sont attendues à cet
effet deè point que je souhaitais
aborder donc la question de la
standardisation et de l'harmonisation à
l'échelle internationale euh cette
question renvoie donc au on l'évoquait
tout à l'heure au nombre des des
réacteurs qui ont vocation à être
construit puisque le le modèle
économique repose sur un effet de série
euh alors nous avons lancé dans le cadre
de l'association des responsables de
sûreté nucléaire d'Europe WENRA un
travail commun sur des objectifs de
sûreté harmonisé pour les petits
réacteurs modulaires donc c'est une base
mais clairement ça n'est pas suffisant
avoir des des objectifs harmonisés ça
n'est pas suffisant pour permettre des
autorisations en des termes identiques
dans différents pays donc avec nos
homologues nous souhaitons aller plus
loin et donc viser cet objectif de de
standardisation ce qui est difficile
parce que la responsabilité en matière
de sûreté nucléaire elle reste une
responsabilité nationale il est
évidemment pas question pour l'ASN ni
pour ses homologues de de prendre à
l'aveugle des autorisations qui auraient
été livrer ailleurs et de les transposer
sans regarder puisqueil y aurait
vraiment une question de responsabilité
qui qui qui se
poserait donc comment faire et bien nous
pensons que la meilleure option c'est
que les autorités nationales se mettent
à travailler ensemble à un stade très
précoce du développement de de de ces
projets à l'examen conjoint d'un même
dossier de
sûreté présenté simultanément dans
plusieurs pays par un même porteur de
projet et sur les quel donc nous
travaillerions ensemble dès le départ et
c'est ce que nous avons fait sur le
projet neward donc à3 d'abord avec donc
l'ASN nos homologues finlandais et nos
homologues tchqu et nous élargissons
dans une phase ultérieure à trois autres
pays les Pays-Bas la pone la Pologne et
la Suède donc vous voyez un examen
conjoint ass si c'est une première à
l'échelle mondiale mais ça me semble
être la voie la plus prometteuse pour
effectivement aboutir à ce que certains
appellent une certification commune
j'aime pas forcément le terme mais en
tout cas l'idée est claire mon dernier
point c'est les pratiques d'instruction
on évoquait le fait que c'est pas tout à
fait la même chose de pour nous de
dialoguer avec un acteur qui est notre
interlocuteur depuis depuis des
décennies et des des des nouveaux
entrants dans le domaine donc nous
devons effectivement faire face à
à une capacité pour nous de monter ce
dialogue avec plusieurs acteurs qui
viennent nous voir simultanément nous
avons à cœur d'ailleurs de les de les
traiter équitablement euh nous avons
pour cela monté une équipe dédiée donc
c'est c'est Philippe Dupuis je l'ai
indiqué qu'il a qu'il a pilote euh et
nous veillons à engager nos
ressources de manière proportionnée à la
maturité des
projets très très bien je vous laisse
conclure je conclus euh pour dire que
ces échanges nous ont permis
d'identifier des questions difficile que
ce soit au plan technique ou juridique
une question un exemple de question
difficile au plan technique c'est le
fait que certains de ces projets
envisage qu'il n'y ait personne sur site
pour l'exploitation c'est c'est une
question question juridique difficile
c'est certains cas un partage de
responsabilité entre le propriétaire du
terrain le propriétaire du réacteur
quand celui enfin quand ces deuxl ne
sont pas les mêmes donc voilà ce sont
des questions que nous que nous
expertisons et je termine en disant que
que nous travaillons sur ces sur ces
sujets techniques réellement main dans
la main avec l'IRSN on a une équipe
conjointe commune qui qui examine et qui
qui est l'interlocuteur des des porteurs
de projets et vraiment tout cela ne se
fera pas que ce soit sur les objectifs
de sûreté la coopération international
et les dialog technique sont des moyens
supplémentaires pour l'ensemble SN RSN
et en tout cas moi je peux vous assurer
que ça ne fera ça ne se fera pas ça se
fera en tout cas sans aucun compromis en
matière de sûreté de rigueur des
démonstrations et de transparence merci
madame la
députée je vous remercie pour ces
explications approfondies à présent j'ai
le plaisir de passer la parole pour
l'IRSN à son directeur général
Jean-Christophe Niel ainsi qu'à sa
directrice générale adjointe en charge
de la Sûreté Nucléaire Karine herview je
vous remercie merci bien merci à
l'office pour nous donner l'occasion
d'inir sur ce sujet donc un un un point
un premier point sur le rôle et les
missions de de l'IRSN sur les smmr alors
l'IRSN historique ement a expertiser des
réacteurs qui sont pas ceux de dfin les
réacteurs exploités aujourd'hui qu'onon
expertise aussi he largement d'ailleurs
on a pu expertiser des des réacteurs
aupressurisés étrangers les VVR
Ukrainiens par exemple ceux de la
propulsion navale puisque comme vous le
savez nous faisons l'appui technique de
l'Autorité de sûreté défense des
réacteurs à neutron rapides phennix
super Phenix et plus réemment Astride et
puis je pourrais mentionner aussi les
réacteurs de génération 4 euh au début
Desné 2000 il y a eu un un un forum qui
s'appelait le le forum génération 4 qui
a lancé l'étude d'un certain nombre de
de filières de réacteur neutron rapide
refroidi au sodium refroidi au gaz
refroidi au plomb des réacteurs à haute
et très haute température des réacteurs
à haut super critique à celle fondu
pourquoi je les mentionne parce que
beaucoup de SMR aujourd'hui utilise ce
type de technologie hein voilà je vais y
revenir alors comme la SN l'a indiqué on
a travaillé sur nos nos no nos modes de
de de d'instruction réglementaire et
d'expertise sur ces smmr innovant il
compris pris dans le cadre des échanges
internationaux puisque nous appuyons
laasn dans le cadre du de l' de l'urly
review sur le New World on a même
travailler sur un un un un processus de
licensing commun qui est là qu'on pourra
vous vous laisser il s'agit évidemment
de renforcer la maîtrise de processus
avec des concepteurs qui sont pas encore
complètement familiers avec d'une part
les réglementations et d'autre part avec
les les approches les attentes en terme
de démonstration de sûreté on pourrait
aussi mettre de sécurité nucléaire les
terroristes de radio prototection on a
par exemple mis en place des processus
de séminaire à propos de la de la
maturité des projets on a identifié des
chefs de projets donc Philippe Dupuit
pour laasn et Sébastien Israël qui est
avec moi derrière donc c'est nos deux
compaires sur ces sur ces sujets et dor
j'ai déjà évidemment laasn l'IRSN a déjà
des contacts plus ou moins avancés avec
l'ensemble des concepteurs qui sont dans
cette salle on a pu donner un avis sur
le dossier d'option de sûreté du
réacteur Jimmy qui est pas représenté
ici et on a reçu C été le dos du
réacteur newward voilà donc c'est des
sujets qui avancent bien alors un mot
sur l'importance de la Red alors comme
vous l'avez noté le niveau de maturité
des projets évidemment variables et il
s'appuie en particulier sur le retour
d'expérience acquis et on peut
considérer à à la je vais donner
quelques chiffrre qui valent le ce qu'
valent mais ils ont un caractère
illustratif on peut dire que les
réacturs eau légère soit pressurisé soit
soit bouillant le retour d'expérience
est très important plusieurs milliers
d'années réacteurs parce que il y a un
peu plus de 400 réacteurs dans le monde
et la plupart sont de cette technologie
les réacteurs à neutron rapide
refroidocium c'est un peu moins mais
c'est quand même plusieurs centaines
d'années réacteurs quand on va vers les
réacturs à basse à haute température on
descend encore d'un cran on est plutôt
autour de la centaine d'anners réacteurs
et pour les autres pour les autres
concepts le retour d'expérience est bien
sûr beaucoup plus limité en tout cas
pour pour pour la majorité de ces
projets il faut des travaux de
Red utile aussi pour la modilisation qui
est nécessaire en support à la
conception c'est le problème des
concepteurs mais aussi la démonstration
de sûreté donc c'est là où ça intéresse
évidemment l'IRSN bon les efforts de Red
ont beaucoup porté historiquement sur
les réacteurs à neutron rapide refroidi
au sodium et sur réacteur haute
température pour raison que j'ai évoqué
puisque c'est des réacteurs qui ont déjà
fonctionné
euh la la plupart des projets propos des
programmes de RD ambitieux avec
notamment réalisation de maquette ou de
de prototype pour disposer une FIDÉ de
données représentatives hein alors dans
le cadre des réacteurs de génération 4
que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure l'IRSN
avait identifié des sujets de Red c'est
dans un rapport de 2014 on vous don la
référence il est publique il est sur
notre site il y avait le sujet des
matériaux hein euh on a par exemple des
des des des des des des environnements à
haute température comme pour le plomb à
400 500° ou des environnements corrosif
hein comme par exemple les selles fondu
donc il y a un enjeu matériux un enjeu
de contrôle he vous savez que c'est
important et c'est l'objet de de de de
sujet de Red de contrôle euh
d'inspection en service des
installations ça peut être lié soit la
compacité des équipements je vous
rappelle c'est des réacteurs modulaires
des petits réacteurs soit à l'opacité
des caloporteurs et on a tous en tête le
sujet des réacteur à neutron rapide
c'est évidemment comme sujet de de de
Red c'est l'étude des des des phénomènes
qui peuvent accompagner ce qui serait
les les accidents graves pour ces
différents réacteurs avec dégagement
d'énergie ou composition des Roget
radioactif ou chimique hein certains
produits chimiques sont pas complètement
anodins évidemment les travaux de R
doivent être menés en lien avec la
filière la filière concernée quelques
considérations de sûreté alors et là je
rejoins ce qu'a dit le directeur général
de de de de de l'ASN hein même si j'agis
de réacteur de plus faible puissance et
on voit d'ailleurs que la gamme de plus
faible puissance elle est large hein
entre des réacteurs de quelques mgaw et
quelques centaines de mgaw même si ces
réacteurs sont plus faible puissance que
le réacteur actuellement en
fonctionnement c'est des réacteurs qui
comportent des quantités importantes de
produits radioactifs dans la mesure où
certains concepteurs envisagent des
usages qui vont conduire à
l'implantation sur les sites à proximité
de zone habité ou de grands sites
industriels les exigences de sûreté
elles doivent permettre de limiter
notablement les conséquences possibles
des situations accidentales
envisageables alors selon la filière la
taille du
réacteur peut avoir un effet sur les
caractéristiques de sûreté qui peut être
plus favorable he suréacteur température
le fait qu'il soit de petite taille va
va va va limiter le comportement
neutronique du cœur donc c'est favorable
euh de manière générale il est utile de
privilégier des des concepts pardonnants
c'est-à-dire qu'il sont peu peu
sensibles aux événements qui peuvent se
produire dans l'installation ou à
l'extérieur de de celle-ci alors il faut
pas oublier ça a été abordé dors et déjà
dans les enjeux de sûreté au-delà de
ceux du réacteur évidemment ceux du
cycle du combustible he puisque ces
réacteurs vont avoir besoin de
combustible éventuellement de
retraitement et donc la sûreté des
installations associées doit commencer
de manière concomitante avec les travaux
sur le réacteur de manière générale en
parer pour les risques les plus
importants nous considérons que la
construction de maquette en appui de la
justification de sûreté des
installations devrait être envisagé par
les concepteur et en tout état de cause
les prototypes devraient être
suffisamment instrumentés de manière
spécifique pour répondre au à la
compréhension nécessaire des sûreté et
je conclus donc au-delà de l'expertise
qu'on apporte à l'ASN l'ASN peut
contribuer à la formation au sujet de la
sûreté nucléaire et de la démonstration
de la Sûreté Nucléaire son appréhension
et nous disposons de code notamment un
code sur les accidents htech qui est qui
est très modulable très adaptable et on
est tout à fait disposer à le partager
avec ceux qui le souhaiteraient j'ai
terminé juste attends merci beaucoup
parfait je vous remercie merci pour vos
exposés je vais repasser la main à
Stéphane piennoir pour le débat final et
les conclusions de cette audition elles
ont là été très passionnante je remercie
l'ensemble des intervenants pour pour
leur
contribution on passe au quelques
questions sur cette sur cet enjeu de de
certification de labellisation on
appellera ça comme vous voulez j'ai une
première question qui est sur
globalement là on va pouvoir couvrir à
la fois les les deux champs d'innovation
aussi bien sur les les REP qui sont plus
connu j'ai pas j'ai pas chiffres sur les
les les centaines d'années de de retour
mais mais aussi sur la les filières
nouvelles euh est-ce qu'on a on a
beaucoup parlé de Phenix super Phenix et
d'Astrid est-ce qu'on a suffisamment
d'éléments
euh des travaux d'Astrid notamment qui
nous permettent d'avoir comment dire de
gagner du temps sur une éventuelle
certification puisque j'insiste
là-dessus mais les start-ups qu'on a
entendu tout à l'heure nous disait que
on avait un horizon assez court à
l'échelle nucléaire 2035 c'est quand
même extrêmement rapide est-ce que vous
considérez l'un et les uns et les autres
que on a un retour d'expérience sur
asrid qui n qui nous permettrait de
certifier plus rapidement les les petits
projets je peut-être regrouper des
questions estce qu'on a Alexandre
savatou qui m'a demandé la
parole et puis monsieur salvon et
Monsieur davier aussi merci monsieur le
Président moi j'aimerais revenir sur la
partie analyse de risque donc comme on
l'a vu ces petits réacteurs plutôt se
mettre dans des sites industriels qui
certains seront probablement des sites
CVO et donc j'ai bien aimé le terme qui
a été utilisé est-ce que les normes qui
sont appliquées pour ces réacteurs
nucléaires sont-ils on va dire
proportionné par rapport aux normes qui
sont appliquées pour le cvzo et sur les
sites industriels sur lesquels ils
seront placés et euh et juste sur
l'analyse de risque euh j'imagine qu'il
y en a qui ont été faites j'imagine pas
que ça n'a pas pu l'être quels sont les
risques concrets car j'ai cru comprendre
qu'il y avait des phénomènes comme la
dilatation des selles liquides ou
d'autres parties de la technologie qui
semblent finalement amoindrir
entre guillemet les dégâts potentiels de
ces installations en cas de problème
merci Daniel salmon merci monsieur le
Président effectivement ça recoupe un
certain nombre de de questions puisque
ce que vous amenez avec ces SMR c'est
vraiment la fonction chaleur qui est
beaucoup prise en compte et qui nous
amène sur du site nucléaire habituel et
donc là vraiment dans des des espaces
qui sont qui vont être plus densifiés en
terme de population avec problématique
parfois du plomb on a vu problématique
du plomb avec l'incendie de Notre-Dame à
Paris le sodium qui a quand même on a
connu super phennix avec quand même de
nombreux soucis avec avec le sodium donc
comment cela va-t-il pris en compte ça
c'est tout ça concerne la sûreté mais on
n pas abordé non plus la sécurité dans
le monde où on est avec la géopolitique
que pensez-vous de la prolifération
c'est la dissémination de sites
nucléaires dans de nombreux endroits en
France mais aussi dans le monde comment
voyez-vous cette problématique parce que
on voit sur l'Ukraine où on a hésité les
Russes ont
bombardé la centrale mais sans aller
trop trop loin mais est-ce que on n aura
pas problématique sur des plus petits
sites où on se dirait voilà c'est moins
grave qu'est-ce que ça va donner
merci Monsieur Davis oui merci beaucoup
c'était vraiment passionnant alors moi
je vais poser des questions un peu
générales et après revenir à à la
question de l'expertise je voulais
revenir juste sur les prémisses
évidemment je pense qu'on est tout ici
convaincu qu'il faut décarboner notre
économie mais moi je ne suis pas
convaincu qu'il faille multiplier sur la
planète par 3 ou par 4 la consommation
d'électricité l'écologue que je suis
parce j'étais avant chercheur sur ces
questions là vous dit que c'est pas
durable pour la planète donc il y a un
moment donné il faut quand même que les
uns et les autres on ai conscience que
multiplié par 3 ou 4 notre consommation
d'électricité c'est derrière faire de la
production c'est derrière des ressources
naturelles des terres rares et cetera et
qu'à l'échelle de 100 200 ans 300 ans ça
ne sera pas durable moi je voulais juste
revenir sur ce qui m'a manqué
aujourd'hui d'abord c'est le fait qu'il
y a pas de bilan des échecs passés euh
il y a eu super Phenix il y a eu Astrid
bon il y a eu le pè on n parle pas
aujourd'hui mais il y a quand même eu
énormément de choses qui ont été faites
et je n'ai pas entendu dans tout ce que
vous avez dit et c'est là aussi où
j'attends beaucoup de l'expertise de
l'ASN et de l'IRSN un bilan critique on
on parle pas de rien quand même et la
plupart d'entre vous d'ailleurs vous
avez travaillé sur ces projets là on les
abandonné pour des raisons politiques
mais aussi pour des raisons techniques
et et scientifique et donc moi je
voudrais quand même vous entendre un
moment donné là-dessus juste après pour
revenir sur la SN et RSN moi ce que je
crain quand je vous entends c'est que
vous êtes beaucoup de start-up c'est
c'est passionnant c'est bien mais vous
êtes quand même dans une logique
communication itionnel quand vous nous
parlez vous essayez de nous convaincre
que c'est génial or moi ce que j'ai
besoin en tant que législateur c'est de
savoir quels sont les verrous à la fois
scientifiquequ et industriel et quels
sont les risques qu'on prend pas que les
risques en terme de sécurité et de et de
et de sûreté mais les risques aussi
économiques au vu de ce qui s'est passé
avec le pè au vu de ce qui s'est passé
avec les les autres les autres projets
et il y a un vrai problème
d'acceptabilité bon et si on veut et si
vous voulez que cette acceptabilité
progresse au niveau de la société il
faut que la sûreté et la sécurité on ait
vraiment confiance d'où le rôle très
important de du travail de l' RSN de
l'ASN on va pas revenir ici sur le débat
de la fusion moi je pense que c'est une
erreur mais moi je me tourne vers vous
comment vous vous pouvez éclairer à la
voix le législateur et les citoyens sur
la pertinence des projets qui sont
déposés et sur la quelle les
caractéristiques en termes de sûreté et
de sécurité pour moi c'est extrêmement
important et si vous arrivez pas à
convaincre des députés et des sénateurs
de la pertinence de tout ça vous ne
convaincrez pas les citoyens
voilà Monsieur L merci beaucoup alors
deux questions rapides la première donc
on a compris que un des avantages
décrits par vous sur les SMR les Amr
c'est le multirecyclage du combustible
dans le cœur bon j'ai quand même une
question c'est que à la fin est-ce qu'on
se retrouve est-ce qu'à un moment faut
quand même sortir du combustible usager
est-ce qu'on se retrouve avec des
déchets et qu'est-ce qu'on en fait euh
et puis après c'est une question aussi
plutôt
pour l'autorité et l'Institut euh moi je
fais partie de ceux qui sont toujours
pas convaincus de l'intérêt de de la
fusion surtout qu'on nous a dit que vous
travaillez déjà en fait en bonne
intelligence notamment sur ces projets
de de réacteur innovant mais dans le
projet de fusion tel qu'il existe à
l'heure actuelle et donc de création de
l'asnr il y a une fusion mais il y a une
séparation de l'expertise de sûreté et
de sécurité dessmr or ça a été rappelé
on va se retrouver avec des réacteurs
qui peut-être peuvent pas exploser pour
les raisons que vous avez indiqué mais
qui se trouvent près de site industriel
et près des habitations est-ce que c'est
vraiment une bonne idée de séparer
l'expertise de sur Sté et de sécurité
dans le cadre de cette
fusion bien on a bien compris qu'on
parlait pas de la fusion nucléaire
euh c'est d'abord la première précision
que je voudrais apporter et comme l'a
dit votre voisin nous n'allons pas ce
n'est pas une audition sur ce projet de
rapprochement entre l'ASN et l' RSN
voilà donc non mais votre voisin est un
petit peu plus comment dire engageant et
pressant sur ce point donc je ne
souhaite pas que voilà c'est pas l'heure
nous avons eu un nous avons une audition
publique he sur ce sujet aujourd'hui
c'est une audition publique sur les
réacteurs innovants voilà donc messieurs
mesdames messieurs vous êtes libre de
répondre à toutes les questions qui
portent sur l'innovation dans le domaine
des réacteurs je vous
remercie prendre la parole pour
commencer monsieur GTA merci monsieur le
Président peut-être je je je je j'entame
et puis je je laisserai
effectivement les autres contributeurs
ici répondre euh sur sur la question
finalement il y a il y a un certain
nombre de questions qui ont tourné
autour de
l'acceptabilité de de ces réacteurs et
ce sur quoi je veux insister c'est que
naturellement la la sûreté le niveau de
sûreté est une condition nécessaire à
l'acceptabilité mais c'est pas une
condition suffisante et donc à un moment
donné il faudra que il y ait créer les
conditions d'un
débat finalement d'une mise sur la table
de l'ensemble des éléments alors c'est
là je je sors c'est c'est pas c'est pas
à l'ASN naturelle de d'organiser ça mais
nous avecn on sera j'imagine prêt à y
contribuer sur les questions de sûreté
nucléaire de radioprotection de
protection de
l'environnement mais il faudra
effectivement à un moment donné mettre
ça sur la table je pense que les le
public aujourd'hui a dans l'idée que les
centrales nucléaires ont vocation pe ou
pro être construite sur des sites
nucléaires ça sera pas le cas avec les
les les nouveaux racteurs et donc il
faut à un moment donné amener ça sur le
sur la table sur la question de la de la
sécurité l'ASN n'est aujourd'hui pas en
charge de ce
sujet par contre très clairement c'est
un sujet qui doit être instruit grosso
modo au même rythme en fait que la
question de la de la Sûreté Nucléaire
elle-même c'est c'est une question de
finalement de calendrier
d'instruction et et si on veut éviter
toute déconvenu en fin de processus il
faut que le le rythme d'instruction
effectivement soit soit le même euh et
et et quant au finalement aux exigences
de sûreté vous évoqueiez à la fois la
proportion et et le fait que que ces
centrales enfin ces réacteurs seraient
sur des sites CVO je il y a il y a deux
éléments il y a effectivement enin trois
éléments il y a le fait que ça a été dit
euh proximité des population ça implique
des objectifs de sûreté renforcé
notamment en terme de de limitation plus
fortes euh des rejets euh il y a un
deuxème élément auquel on pense pas
toujours qui est que quand on est sur un
site cvau finalement il peut y avoir une
rétroaction de de l'usine chimique ou de
l'usine quelle qu'elle soit sur le
réacteur lui-même et ça il faut que ça
soit traité d'une façon ou d'une autre
je pense que les porteurs de projets en
en sont conscients ils travaillent avec
cette objectif là aussi et puis bien
entendu mais ça c'est constant euh dans
dans notre doctrine ASN et IRSN la
fixation des exigences de sûreté elle
est à proportion des enjeux de sûreté on
réglemente pas on exige pas la même
chose d'une grosse installation qui
présente des risques importants et d'une
toute petite installation qui présente
très peu de risque là on est sur des
objets intermédiaires voil on est
effectivement alors pour les plus petits
d'entre eux du moins parce que quand on
commence à approcher la centaine de mgaw
on est quand même assez voilà c'est a
des caractéristiques aussi FA mais ça ça
commence à ressembler quand même
beaucoup à une installation nucléaire de
base sur des tout petits réacteurs on
est sur des des objets plus
intermédiaires mais avec malgré tout des
démonstrations de sûreté qui qui
requièrent un certain niveau de rigueur
voilà
oui pour pour apporter des compléments
sur ce sujet de l'aspect proportionné
aux enjeux euh donc effectivement en
France notre réglementation en matière
nucléaire est c'est on va dire légère
elle est surtout fondée sur des
objectifs de démonstration non pas sur
des moyens donc on n'est pas écrasé par
des normes la la charge de la preuve est
à apporter comme ça a été rappelé
précédemment par les exploitants ensuite
cette aspect proportionné aux enjeux et
qui est lié aussi éventuellement avec à
quelle vitesse on est capable de faire
ça il faut bien définir le mot enjeu ici
le mot enjeu n'est pas rattaché
uniquement à la taille du réacteur
l'enjeu il est apporter également alors
ça ça a été expliqué par
l'IRSN c'est pas parce qu' un réacteur
est pas très puissant qu'il n'est qu'il
ne contient pas un une quantité de
matière radioactive importante car
contrairement au réacteurs dont vous
avez l'habitude des réacteurs REP qui
sont rechargés à peu près tous les ans
ou tous les 2 ans certains de ces
réacteurs sont chargés une première fois
et ont durée de vie avec un même cœur
pendant 20 ans en fait ils ont un
inventaire de départ qui est quand même
énorme et ils arrivent la duré parce
qu'ils ont une faible puissance voilà
donc ce n'est pas la puissance qui fait
l'enjeu intrinsè de sûreté ensuite il y
a cet enjeu qui a été rappelé proximité
des populations et ensuite il y a un
autre enjeu qui est celui de
l'innovation
euh on rappelle on attend une
démonstration et une exigence
essentielle en matière de sûreté c'est
le caractère éprouver des solutions qui
sont proposées pour euh un site
industriel vous voulez un réacteur ind
industriel il faut des solutions éprouvé
sinon il faut passer d'abord par une
étap par un réacteur expérimental et
donc ces réacteurs il y a un enjeu
également qui va nécessiter du temps de
l'expertise de la part d' RSN sur
l'expertise de ce caractère innovant
voilà donc cette notion de proportionnel
à l'enjeu voilà ne restez pas uniquement
sur le fait que c'est petit donc il y a
pas
d'enjeu faire une réponse à de voix
Karine donc sur la sur la sur la
question présente sur industriel c'est
un sujet important dans dans l'expertise
de Surtel l'IRSN on va regarder l'effet
du réacteur sur son environnement donc
par exemple s un accent nucléaire quel
est l'impact sur les installations
industrielles ça se pose c'est une
question qu'on regarde déjà par à
Graveline où il y a beaucoup
d'installations industrielles autour
d'abord l'opérateur qui regarde cette
question et on l'expertise effectivement
ça a été dit très justement il y a
évidemment l'effet inverse c'est
l'impact de
l'installation à risque sur sur sur
l'installation nucléaire
au Tricastin par exemple et regarder
l'effet des des barches qui peuvent
transporter des des gaz explosifs à
proximité de la centrale c'est parti su
ça c'est le premier point le le deuxième
point sur la question comment éclairer
les parlementaires ben aujourd'hui il
faut être clair sur ce sujet des smmr
l'expertise deinstitut de l'Institut
commence he j'ai évoqué le dos sur la le
dossier d'option de sûreté surqu on a
mis un avis pour le acteur Jimmy mais
pour l'instant on n pas on n pas de
d'objet très finalisés mais bien
évidemment dès qu'ils seront finalisés
cette expertise pourra et sera présentée
au parlementaires ce sera intéressant
justement de de de voir les enjeux qui
distinguent ces réacteur d'un point de
vue démonstration de sûreté expertise de
sûreté directeur de de de de puissance
actuelle et je propose que Karine tu
nous fasses un point sur les RNR super
phenit Astrid oui donc un petit point
sur Astrid votre question monsieur
Président c'est finalement est-ce que le
travail qui a été fait sur Astrid
permettait de de gagner du temps sur sur
les projets alors on n'est pas allé très
loin finalement en terme terme
d'expertise hein puisquon on s'en est
arrêté à l'examen d'un d'un dossier
d'orientation de sûreté ceci dit ça a
permis quand même de se caler sur les
exigen de sûreté
attendu et donc le le projet en tout cas
exana a un ensemble d'exigences sur
lesquels nous nous avons convenu de de
travailler à l'époque notamment tout ce
qui est inspection service typiquement
donc j'imagine que que le CEA a a repris
ses ses exigences et et que les
start-ups que nous avons en face de nous
en ont bien
conscience dans le cadre de ce document
on avait effectivement fait un bilan
complet du retour d'expérience de
conception et d'exploitation donc des
réacteurs Phénix super phéx rapsudi
également qui permettaiit de de tenir
compte de ce retour d'expérience pour
définir à la fois les exigences et les
solutions attendues de façon générale en
France on a une compétence avérée sur la
réacteur au sodium et on maîtrise on
peut considérer qu'on maîtrise cette
réaction sodium ha on a des disp
position en tout cas sur les gros
réacteurs qui étaient éprouvés
maintenant il faut voir comment ça se
transfère à des petits réacteurs hein
puisque le le principe du de la maîtrise
était d'écarté finalement les endroits
où on a du sodium des endroits où où il
y a de l'eau hein donc là sur un design
compact évidemment c'est une question
qui qui reviendra qui reviendra sur sur
la table de façon plus générale on avait
convenu que sur le projet Astrid le
niveau de sûreté atteignable était
équivalent à à ce qu'on trouve
aujourd'hui sur sur les PR pour les
autres les autres technologies les
autres filières comme on l'a vu dans
dans le cadre de de nos échanges avec le
le general for International Forum et le
rapport donc qui est publque on a
identifié un certain nombre de à la fois
de verrou technologiqu et de points qui
devaent absolument être approfondis en
terme de démonstration de sûreté et qui
appelle effectivement des des travaux de
Red par parfois conséquent sur le plomb
évaluer les rejets en cas d'accident de
fusion du cœur par exemple c'est des
c'est des éléments et connaissances des
phénomènes que nous n'avons pas sur le
sel fondu il y a également beaucoup de
Red qui est nécessaire alors il y a des
il y a des ces prometteurs par exemple
si je prends le cas des des réacteurs
sel fondu il y a plus vraiment de
problème de réactivité mais on est loin
encore aujourd'hui de de la
démonstration que devront apporter les
les différents porteurs de de
projets j'ai indiqué tout à l'heure les
les start-up de la première table ronde
pouvaient tout à fait réagir à cette
sollicitation de de certification et aux
questions qui ont été posées je bien
parler un peu un peu du sodium
effectivement pour la question du
président piernoir sur sur le
rexastride tout ce qui a été fait
pendant 10 ans sur la sûreté
effectivement il y a eu un dossier
d'orientation de sûreté soumis il y a eu
un dossier d'option de sûreté écrit qui
a pas eu le temps d'être soumis
néanmoins toute cette connaissance là
nous on on veut la valoriser dans exana
on va s'appuyer dessus c'est pas un
copiercollé exana il y a des choses qui
sont un petit peu différentes mais
effectivement les exigences déjà qu' qui
sont connues les 20 recommandations de
la SN de l'époque on les connaît on va
les prendre en compte
après je dirais on fait pas un
copiercollé non plus d'Astrid juste pour
le plaisir d'accélérer et de reprendre
les choses quoi donc il y aura quand
même des des choses un peu différentes
sur la question du Rex sodium un peu
plus généralement pour le sénateur
salmon euh nous on considère que ce Rex
c'est un patrimoine scientifique et
technique extrême précieux dont on peut
être fier on peut être fier de phennix
de super Phenix super Phenix en 96 c'est
un taux de disponibilité 96 % c'est plus
de 3,7 TWh de produit d'électricité bas
carbone c'est aucune file de sodium
aucune réaction sodiumo phennix qui est
un réacteur expérimental a eu des files
sodium et des réactions sodiumau 5
réactions sodiumo aucune conséquen sur
l'environnement ou les personnes une
trentaine de fu sodium maximum 2 kg très
peu petite fite l'exploitant c'est géré
c'est un risque industriel on vidange le
circuit on répare on ressoude on remplit
on contrôle on remplit le circuit on
redémarre moi j'en ai vécu deux à Phenix
en 2007 200009 c'est un problème
industriel avant tout parce que voilà
qu'on qu'on sait gérer je rappellerai
aussi que le sodium le premier
producteur mondial de sodium il est
français c'est l'élément le c'est un
élément très connu dans l'industrie on
fait des batteries au sodium il y a des
concepts de solaire à concentration qui
utilisent du sodium liquide le sodium
c'est aussi un pharmaceutique et cetera
et cetera donc c'est un fluide
industriel qui présente des risques des
risques connus des risques maîtrisés par
les technologies et par le r
d'exploitation le Rex d'exploitation de
phenniix et super Phenix nous dans exana
on on l'embarque avec notre partenaire
EDF sur la pay background de tous
d'exploitation parce que notre objectif
c'est effectivement pas de se faire
plaisir avec un réacteur d'ingénieur
mais de faire un réacteur d'exploitant
qui intègre tout ça parce queà la fin ça
était très bien rappelé c'était le
propos liminire de d'Olivier Gupta sur
c'est la responsabilité de l'exit de
l'exploitant donc ce r que clà nous on a
bien intégré et puis euh je voulais dire
aussi euh deux petites question je pense
cétait député léné ou peut-être d'avis
sur l'aspect un peu durable et la
consommation d'électricité va augmenter
et que voilà euh un réacteur sodium le
multirecyclage la fermeture du cycle on
a plus de mine d'uranium on valorise les
340000 tonnes d'uranium appauvri qui
sont sur notre sol on valorise le
plutonium des combustibles usés et avec
des concepts en isogénération comme
exana ou stellaria on on peut aller vers
le nucléaire durable avoir des une
autonomie énergétique très grande
l'impact climatique le RNR ça sort à 2 g
de CO2 par kWh parce que la moitié de
l'impact environnemental du nucléaire
c'est les mines et l'enrichissement plus
de mines plus d'enrichissement divise
par de toutes les externalités sur
l'environnement du nucléaire 2 g de CO2
par kilwh c'est 5 fois moins qu'une
éolienne 10 fois moins qu'un panneau
solaire donc on est bien dans le monde
de l'ultra bas carbone et sur les
matériaux critiques alors naturellement
le RNR il est très peu gourmand en
matériaux critique le sodium c'est le 6e
élément le plus présent dans la coude
terrestre mais aussi on a veillé à pas
avoir de lithium de cobalt de graphite
et cetera et cetera et donc c'est c'est
un réacteur qui est très sobre aussi de
ce point de vue-là énergétiquement
climatiquement mais aussi du point de
vue des des mator critiques et donc
quand on parle de nucléaire durable avec
les RNR c'est pas une vue de l'esprit
c'est qu'on a regardé tous les critères
et enfin la question du multi recyclage
est-ce qu'il y a des déchets bah là faut
être très clair le nucléaire sans
déchets ça existe pas moi je suis pas là
pour vous vendre un nucléaire sans
déchets à la fin il y a toujours des
déchets la vertu du RNR c'est qu'on
diminue grandement la quantité et la
dangerosité des déchets la radiotoxicité
parce que le plutonium n'est plus un
déchet et une ressource quelque part un
peu infini et donc à la fin on a les
produits de fission durée de vie 300 ans
qu'on peut mettre dans les vers et les
actinines mineures alors soit on les met
tous soit on fait un peu de
transmutation pour diminuer la durée
mais à la fin ils existent quand même
mais on diminue grand ement quand même
la quantité la radiotoxicité des déchets
ça c'est aussi pas une vue de l'esprit à
phenniix on a tout ce re là les calculs
on sait les faire je pense que c'était
la RAD pareil d' juste pour dire que
tout ce qui a été dit pour les RN RNA
vaut à nouveau pour tous les
rapides j'aimerais ajouter que notre
engagement ici c'est c'est avant tout un
engagement
environnemental le je voulais revenir
sur différ en point euh le taux de
retour énergétique euh est exceptionnel
faut voir que le taux de retour
énergétique du pétrole ne cesse de
baisser on est autour de de 15 à 20
alors qu'on est à 60 au début du siècle
dernier le taux de retour énergétique en
dessous de 10 c'est-à-dire que combien
vous allez mettre finalement vous allez
mettre un litre de pétrole et combien de
lites d'équivalent euh pétrole décarboné
vous allez récupérer de l'installation
c'est ça qui est important donc un taux
de de retour énergétique inférieur à 10
ça ne permet pas d'avoir une société
moderne c'est-à-dire d'avoir des un
système de retraite un système éducatif
un système de santé et cetera donc nous
le taux de retour énergétique il est
supérieur à 100 et c'est c'est
exceptionnel voilà donc ça signifie que
pourquoi on a ça parce que on a
justement plus besoin de de mines on est
capable de récupérer toutes les matières
existantes et et on fournit beaucoup
d'énergie hein la densité c'est il y a
un facteur 1 million entre 1 g d'uranium
et et 1 L de pétrole un facteur 70
million entre des batteriesons lithium
et des piles d'un nouveau genre que sont
le le
Stellarium et puis je voulais revenir
sur les zones ATEX et les zones
explosives ou C vaau qui peuvent exister
en effet on prend ça en compte très
sérieusement dès le départ dans la
conception avec un réacteur qui est qui
qui est quasiment entièrement enterré et
euh une capacité à tenir le séisme de ce
fait donc pour nous c'est c'est quelque
chose de très important le fait d'être
basse pression le fait d'avoir des
selles
inertes du nal c'est du sel de table
donc c'est pas vraiment comme le sel de
table parce qu'on on a pris le comme
disait Christophe Le nal 37 mais c'est
25 % du sel de table donc voilà c'est
c'est en jeu de durabilité de quantité
de service et de sécurité dès le départ
pris en compte
juste un petit complément sur le le
retour d'expérience dont vous parlez et
et les enseignements qu'on peut tirer de
des des installations existantes et des
des
exploitations sur la partie fabrication
du combustible MOX RNR l'un d'entre vous
fait référence évidemment au à
l'exploitation de Melox c'est un point
qui est qui a été extrêmement étudié
pris en compte on a travaillé sur le le
Rex de des installations existantes et
un certain nombre amélioration et de de
de modification en ce sens à apporter
sur sur l'installation de fabrication de
MOX RNR euh dans les dans le cadre de
notre projet et et et sur l'acceptation
du public il faut quand même
aussi rappeler que le le concept même de
de de de la fermeture du cycle du
combustible contribue grandement à à cet
effet même si effectivement ensuite les
un certain nombre de de de de de points
complémentaires précis économique
technique doivent être adressés mais on
est quand même dans un cadre général
assez favorable sur ce
planl je voulais intervenir également
pour juste pour souligner qu'il fallait
pas réduire je dirais le l'utilisation
des des SMR au au sites industriels et C
VO dans la mesure où il y a d'autres
applications alors j'en ai pas cité mais
le le modèle de développement du du
neward c'est d'aller remplacer des
centrales charbon de profiter du foncier
disponible de la connexion au réseau de
la source froide pour réduire et
décarboner ces ces ces moyens de
production là voilà après il est
possible d'en mettre à proximité mais
après on adapte effectivement le
dimensionnement et les conditions
d'exploitation en fonction des des
contraintes
oui je CIS savoir qu'il y a une
présidente de région qui s'estexprimaé
dans ce sens-là dans une région que je
connais un petit peu pour remplacer une
centrale à charbon euh Olga je voudrais
juste ajouter un petit point si vous me
le permettez sur l'analyse de risque qui
est fondamentale notre question c'est le
travail d'un industriel son ADN c'est de
partir d'une analyse de risque et on est
on va très très loin dans les analyses
de risque on se pose même des questions
avec des occurrences qui n'existent pas
et on se pose les questions parce qu'on
essaie d'intégrer ça dans nos dans nos
design le plus en amont possible on l'a
très bien rappelé vous avez une liste
d'exigences extrêmement forte que nous
prenons à part entière sans jamais
déroger et en plus de ça on essayer d'en
mettre des supplémentaires donc cette
analyse de risque c'est l'ADN des
industriels c'est comme ça qu'on
développe absolument tout c'est capital
sinon ce sera inacceptable la deuxième
chose sur retour d'expérience on a posé
la question sur le retour des échecs
passés alors bien évidemment les
autorités l'ont fait c'est parfait mais
nous aussi on l'a fait parce que dans
nos équipes vous avez à peu près un/5e
de nos équipes ce sont des seniors qui
ont travaillé sur tous les projets dont
nous avons parlé avant Phenix super
Phenix Astride c'est énorme ça veut dire
qu'on va chercher ce qui est dans la
tête de ces gens-là parce qu'ils n'ont
pas couché sur le papier ce ce retour
d'expérience et on leur demande de
transmettre à des jeunes si on regarde
le plan match qui a été très bien fait
par le gifen sur les 100000 emplois dont
nous aurons besoin sur les 10 prochaines
années nous devons participer à ce
transfert de savoir faire aux jeunes
générations et ça c'est un engagement de
toute la filière que nous devons
considérer nous en France car personne
d'autre ne le fait
ailleurs Mons Sala oui moi je voulais
faire un commentaire sans revenir sur le
les les études de risque mais évoquer
que le le débat mais met quand même en
évidence un point qui est le la
nécessité d'innover donc on a des des
sujets qui sont qui sont complexes des
des questions qu'il faut traiter
collègues de de l'IRSN laasn on ont
évoqué les les besoins de de recherche
je voudrais vraiment plaider pour
renforcer tout le soutien qui peut être
fait autour de l'innovation de la
recherche les les démarches qui ont été
mises en œuvre au titre d'abord de
francerance puis ensuite de France 2030
ont permis de lancer cette cette
démarche là qui est un un très très beau
succès mais comme on peut le constater
il y a qu beaucoup de chemins à faire et
donc ce rôle de de l'état de de soutien
mais aussi de fédération des acteurs de
dynamisme que vous apportez aussi au
sein de de l'opest est à mon avis un
facteur très très important pour
résoudre les les nombreuses questions
qui nous restent encore à traiter le
deuxième point également dont on n pas
beaucoup parlé c'est la dimension
européenne donc aujourd'hui plusieurs
pays européens sont très très intéressés
par le le redémarrage ou la construction
de nouveaux réacteurs des nouvelles
façons de travailler sont nécessaires
hein je pense que Olivier Goutta l'a
évoqué très très très très clairement
mais les enjeux d'innovation sont
tellement importants qu'il serait
probablement intéressant de considérer
de les partager entre plusieurs pays
européens et et de fédérer aujourd'hui
des des des actions sur le sur le plomb
hein puisque collègues de plomb sont
tout proches il y a des acteurs qui font
des réacteurs au plomb en Italie a des
acteurs qui font des réacteurs au plomb
en Belgique il y a des acteurs qui font
des réacteurs au plomb en Suède et on
peut dire la même chose également sur
les sur les autres technologies qui sont
qui sont ici autour de de la table donc
un volet je dirais de de dimension
européenne auprès bien sûr des pays
intéressés et est un levier sans doute
très très important que la
représentation parlementaire aussi
pourrait promouvoir
oui alors nous avons une question en
ligne que je souhaiterais vous relayer
euh concernant l'ASN et et l'IRSN la
question euh est dans le cadre de
notamment nos réacteurs innovants euh
les moyens qui vous sont àoué sont-ils à
la hauteur des enjeux et des ambitions
gouvernementales et pour compléter cette
question effectivement moi j'ai eu des
des remontées par rapport à justement
l'embauche et la capacité de s'aligner
par rapport à d'autres autorités euh qui
euh peuvent embaucher à des salaires euh
plus plus intéressants et comment la
l'ASN et l'IRSN sont-elles compétitif
par rapport à cela pour attirer les
compétences
merci très bien merci madame la députée
je je commence et puis je je vais
immédiatement CER la parole à
Jean-Christophe ni côté côtén alors on
on est en train de gréer une équipe
autour de de Philipp DEP puit donc voilà
là on pour j'allais dire pour l'année
2024 on on on a les les les moyens donc
c'est quelques c'est quelques personnes
ça va pas chercher très loin à ce stade
euh mais effectivement euh vous avez
tout à fait raison enfin personne qui
POS la question a tout à fait raison il
va falloir que l'effort se poursuive
dans la durée c'est il y aura forcément
une montée en puissance là on évoquait
on a des discussions préliminaires qui
sont extrêmement intéressantes hein et
je veux pas sous-estimer bien au
contraire le la qualité des discussions
qu'il y a dès à présent mais ça va
devoir monter en puissance donc
naturellement euh voilà c'est ces moyens
ils vont devoir continuer d'être
renforcés dans les années à venir et ça
c'est dans les mains du gouvernement et
dans les mains du
Parlement alors sans surprisein euh
quand l'ASN a des besoins en amont
l'IRSN a des besoins puisque l'IRSN fait
l'expertise pour pour la SN aujourd'hui
on a un nombre limité de personnes je
fais RD plus expertise ça fait moins de
5 personnes donc il y a un besoin réel
he qu'on a évaluer il nous faudrait
brève échéance une douzaine de
personnes aujourd'hui les les travaux
dont j'ai évoqué le travail qu'on a fait
sur le dos de Jimmy on a ça a été
discuté avec les porteurs de projets et
avec l'ASN on aura euh dans dans le
courant du premier semestre 2024 un
certain nombre de rendez-vous sur nos en
utilisant des méthodes qu'on a développé
d'ailleurs sur des projets comme le P et
le PR2 au base de séminairees et
aujourd'hui par exemple on envisage un
séminaire par mois par concept par
thématique thématique c'est accident
grave c'est agression c'est voilà donc
c'est quand même ça va être conséquent
he donc la montée en puissance va être
là et et et et si on n pas les moyens
supplémentaires il y a pas de secret
hein ça se fait par redéploiement en
discussion avec
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire ça veut
dire que c'est prélev des moyens
ailleurs pour les mettre sur ces sujets
là c'est même sujet qu'on c'est la
manière don on fonctionne en
général bien monsieur mesames et
Messieurs je vous remercie pour pour
pour ces échanges nombreux et et
vraiment très très enrichissant et merci
à vous tous vraiment d'avoir d'avoir
participé je remercie aussi mes mes
collègues d'avoir été présents on voit
que c'est un un sujet qui intéresse la
représentation nationale comme on dit
j'ai à titre personnel relevé quand même
quelques quelques points saillants avec
des pistes prometteuse sur la filière
des des RNR hein pour faire suite au
projet de réacteur à neutron rapide
Astrid qui a été largement évoqué
pendant ce cette matinée et donc ce qui
vise à assurer conformément à notre loi
la fermeture du cy qui je le rappelle
est toujours inscrite dans notre dans
nos codes euh mentionner que quelque
chose sur le terme international quand
même le Japon he qui était notre
principal partenaire sur Astrid et on on
sait à quel point on connaît le leur
désarroi au moment où la la France a
choisi de de stopper euh provisoirement
peut-être mais en tout cas de stopper en
2019 ce ce programme et il a ce Japon
élargi son accord avec la la start-up
américaine Terra power pour la
conception de de ce type de recteur ce
qui prouve d'ailleurs que la France
n'est pas totalement isolée dans cet
objectif d'aller vers des ce qu'on a
appelé le le nucléaire durable vous vous
en doutez bien que l'ofice va va
continuer à suivre de de très très près
tous ces sujets liés à la filière
nucléaire en en général qui évolue très
rapidement je l'ai dit tout à l'heure et
comme les les confirment les dernières
informations venant de l'étranger en
particulier des États-Unis mais aussi
des pays européens qui se qui se mettent
dans dans le mouvement et nous aurons
peut-être d'autres auditions plus
spécifiquement consacré au au cycles euh
voilà j'ai souhaité qu'on s'en tienne au
réaccteurs aujourd'hui i l'aval et la
monte du cycle ne sont jamais très loin
quand on évoque toutes ces questions là
mais pour des questions de de condensé
et de de d'fficience de cette audition
publique j'ai souhaité qu'on qu'on aille
pas plus loin pour aujourd'hui pour
cette matinée merci vraiment à à tous et
je suis convaincu que nous serons amenés
à nous retrouver dans les prochaines
semaines dans les prochains mois bon
courage à tous
merci